[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo
what's going on around
what is going on
tough morning to get up to
yeah new york new jersey
tri-state
little weather you know what i mean
temperature dip down a little bit not
feeling the greatest but we got a power
to the room yeah i'm saying my brother
solved give us all some love y'all he's
um going through it right now he's got
he got called in to work
so i don't know if we're going to guess
all but we might have some people on
deck for replacements shout out to back
for that raiding with you last night
shout out to iop destiny clan salute man
you're doing your thing brother it was a
lot of fun even even when he's messing
up
it was a lot of fun but me and you were
holding we did our job back we were
holding down them sides we was helping
the the dude the caretaker you know guys
that would try to shock you man you know
it's trying to stun them you know we did
our thing but uh anyway sith lord what's
going on d178 what's up the joker saint
what's going on gerald mack always shout
out to general mac he be holding it down
salute to the video salute to the love
you know what i'm saying i see you lydia
master what's going on i see you but
yeah we got it i got a cool little show
oh dr 78 from the uk what part of the uk
big up big up big up uk what's going on
i got a fair amount there i got fear of
london
stratton all that i be out there i'm
worldwide when it comes worldwide with
it so dr put put up where you from in
the uk you know what i'm saying i got
fam out there
mass produced what's good familia what's
going on
attic will be rolling in
king will be rolling in you know saying
we all low
it's a little sluggish it's like it's
sunday but we're gonna get some cooking
for y'all man we gonna get stuck cooking
that got a lot of good topics though
topics are lit so i'm excited for that
but uh yeah it's gonna be a fun one it's
gonna be a fun one wait for addict to
pull up check out the levels make sure
my levels
lately the level's been all over the
place you gotta correct it the fans you
guys are absolutely correct i brought
myself down just a little bit
because i want to make sure that i'm not
overpowering
um attic or anybody else on the mic i
know addicts to having his issues
whatever
[Music]
let's get it you already know yeah we
got some fun today for sure we always
have fun
also packs he's just happening you know
what i'm saying uh unkept talks hello i
appreciate y'all making it to the live
show no doubt no doubt yeah it's gonna
be a fun month man we got a lot planned
this month pax he says this month
oh manchester okay north uk in the
building you already know see pier xxx
new pricing plan i did not do me but i
did now i gotta go check that out kevin
list what's going on
but um yeah man we're gonna get
everybody in the room
see what's going on with um
king
and he'll be in shortly and then of
course attic and uh yeah we may have
some surprises
so look i hear y'all appreciate your mac
thank you for the for the sound check my
check make sure i'm doing okay out there
use these hustles big cloud whoa big
cloud you may have to check your dms
brother
fake cloud let's go in on
all right it's been a minute leading to
good to see you brother you are
absolutely my friend let's give big
crowd flowers
he been doing
he's been doing a long time he's a he's
a professional that ryan
[Laughter]
but i want to say live oh eggs i don't
think we give a lot a lot of fellow
content creators and flowers brother i
am
proud of you and i love what you're
doing right now
you're doing things you create your own
lane
and your blessings are coming forth so
yeah yeah you will see your dms in a
minute i got you
oh mitch he dies a lot what's up what's
going on you already know i got you bro
i got you it's coming through it's
coming through so look let me get going
because king will come in with the music
big cloud i'ma holla and um yeah see
y'all in a few
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arcing up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
rings you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my
[Music]
dog thing very loyal but i ain't gonna
hold you i ain't here to boy you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all have missed up and turned me
to an animal and had this be swearing
they real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the snapple and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire's plain they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell the uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
on twitter but i'm anti-social love my
city but i'm still by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
who
let's do that again it's not even
moseyed download to the website go check
it out whether you're going to get that
focus for the gaming session the energy
a little perk for the gym we want to get
some swag some merch maybe an ice shaker
go run on over there check out the
products man again really cool products
they don't hide behind any type of
proprietary blend
nonsense it's all transparent as far as
the ingredients the label green tea
caffeine kind of a healthy form of
natural caffeine none of that crash none
of that stuff so yeah again go check it
out you run in there you add it to your
cart use that referral link that we got
in the description and then you make
sure on the checkout you're putting in
iron lord again iron lord on the
checkout get yourself a nice discount
when you're checking out advanced gg and
like i said try the product for yourself
see what you think about it the lords we
love it and we are powered by advanced
gg so check that thing out
[Music]
which lies
[Music]
just chill and watch them any snacks in
the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for addict if i
can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david royalty not a
pretender detrimental to an elemental
what's an avatar to a knee bender i
gotta be me though i know it's my
destiny words incognito who cares if you
fly if you steal a mosquito you swearing
away something but really be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible other than nothing
is cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right hear ye hear ye you know do a
quick question yeah i see i see levels i
said so i'll make sure we'll make sure
you're not at levels b he hear ye and we
are live welcome to the iron laws
podcast llc and also the lords of
gaming.net
episode number 251 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table
with the lord's day 251 it was that was
kind of kind of
crazy and today we've got playstation
plus
revamped u.s senators wait wait wait
wait
yes it ain't spartacus
they are officially calling it
playstation plus
wow
u.s senators versus microsoft activism
undead lab allegations and of course
damn i forgot to put the e3
e3 2022 unprofessional cog e3 2022
castle to be discussed so let's
introduce damn we down one lord we're
down one lord everyone's sending their
love to solve there's a chance there is
a chance he could it's funny because all
right you got to start saying send your
love because they really think this dude
is sick or something and he'd be dying
or something he at
so let's just say yeah okay okay but he
at work so let's just say yo
say what's up to sob when you see him
right
hopefully he'll get here
say you love the song cause king don't
kill it
he's not sick guys
[ __ ] be making it seem like we about to
start a go fund me for
it's like i look on twitter and people
like solve get well
listen man brother's hurting
but anyway
my goal is to go folks my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord addict
of the attic show how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh you know it's it's
it's been a crazy week
uh i do want to point out that i went to
the store yesterday and i got this i
don't know why but like this was just
screaming my name yeah i'm sure people
in the chat know what this is i'm not
explaining well anime referenced that my
old self don't know what it is yeah yeah
you'll be fine
i mean unless it's like on the back oh
no it just says his name
but yeah i'm sure someone in the chat
will say it
but uh it's it's been a good week man we
uh we we played a destiny raid didn't
finish it yesterday
uh so hopefully
[Music]
i kindly stepped away from the pool yeah
you've been stepping away for a while
[Laughter]
what else you were playing man
that's all that's it just besides
raiding with us late last night nothing
else and eldon ring yeah
yeah i'm literally on elder ring all i'm
doing is just
showing up in like two shots and bosses
for people
what's funny is i've been on this
this new rampage where people keep
saying that
that
magic is broken and elden ring
and i got this shill that's more broken
than any magic i've ever seen in eldon
ring
and i'm going to like the hardest bosses
in the game and showing to them
at least with a mage you have to dodge
sure you got long range distance axe
king i don't have to do anything but
hold left left
that's all i have to do left bumper and
then hit this over and over again that's
all
cause he can't hit me that's the key
usually the way that they balance eldon
ring in any kind of from software's game
is
when you block it takes your statum but
this particular shield has really high
uh defense so it doesn't take as much
data but but when you when you com when
you
add it with the great shield but it
takes even less
so it literally would take like let's
say my but my standard bar is this long
it takes like this is literally how long
it goes before it goes down oh it'll be
going slow
all i have to do is just stop moving
but but magic is the is the cheese magic
is the gym the magic's the cheese what's
funny is like people are talking about
broken weapons it's not magic the moon
veils they're getting
the rivers of blood like bg in a chat
salute he said greeting all the window
jumpers out there we love you
[Laughter]
talking about them um spartacus lovers
did you use the movie jump pg oh
what not the the bg in the past
boys you can't be shots at weapons
i know that whatever
good to see you up in the realm and of
course king does not want me to say any
good things to saul but solve
that
he just said stop acting like he on
death bed all right so
song's at work y'all's at work hopefully
there you go he will join us but um
anyway we got the incredible hulk of
this aka the excess gamer oh
the prophet of xbox rummy king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement oh be
love it lord king how are we doing sir
i'm doing fantastic it's a a great
weekend it's it's very nice a lot of
things is going on stuff is moving and
shaking i didn't get a chance to go see
morbius like i hoped
and prayed that i'd be able to do so
this time sometime this week um
i don't care about
the frauds talking about it's the worst
marvel movie
uh ever you don't know the characters
shut up
it's not a marvel movie it's a sony
movie he's a marvel character the movie
was made by sony that's what we do
we doing this already we gonna do that
because kevin feige got his hands in it
and it says marvel and not in
association with oh lord you know how
that go okay okay i see what you're
doing yeah you know the checks go to
sony mm-hmm
act like the checks ain't going to them
i mean sony has made good movies like
like sure like they're not is here's the
thing like you can't expect a marvel
type movie with the the universe they've
built in marvel from individual video
movies that sony key's making like they
haven't built that universe it's
impossible to beat that quality right
yeah listen i honestly get it um they
just did spiderman the spiderman was
phenomenal so you know a lot of people
want to say oh once on spider-man's
phenomenal it's a sony movie oh when
morbius is whacked
[Music]
we're going to leave that on no we ain't
going to do that today sir
shout out to the raven blade remember 14
month lord bronze he said hello everyone
it's that time ilp time i'm happy that i
got to the mountaintop after clapping
them two bosses yes magic is broken
broken mimic and azure combo
attic
oh yeah i mean i guess he's talking
about like dual camera waves or like the
the mimic is pretty much a clone of
yourself cause whatever armor you have
the moment you pop the mimic it makes a
clone of yourself to fight alongside you
yeah but the thing about that is they
kind of nerfed it like in the beginning
the first couple of weeks it was crazy
broken but i never got to it i got a
problem man oh what's up all right
because you know i'm playing this elden
ring and i see these dudes out here
running around with the 200s and the
179's and
all that i put in literally probably six
seven hours a day you know and chris got
mad at me because chris was like yo
you know
you you're playing the game all day but
you're not going the way you're supposed
to go to
that's the point of the game
how the hell am i supposed to
go to that place where it is dangerous
like literally dangerous wait hold on
you avoid you invite you avoiding old
block
no well the thing is you can't go to old
black without your vest okay what i do
is i get stronger get my vest then walk
over the old block okay so
he he had me in blood manor
and
if anybody knows what blood man is
it's like castlevania
this game got so many hints of every
other thing
it's so nice okay so i'm in blood manner
and then they tell you they send you on
missions to take out people across the
map
so i got the missions and i did them and
then you get good armor and stuff like
that so you know to chris who said i'm
not doing everything i'm not trying to
finish my 70 game in a day okay i'm not
trying to get to the ending all fast i'm
i'm exploring the wonderful world and
the end of a generation because this
game is not a true next generation game
oh
let's keep a buck let's keep it up oh
you're coming around come around
it's not it's not a true next generation
game it's oh well this generation game
it's the last generation game it's the
ending of a great last generation yeah
and to be honest with you like the
loading screens are kind of longer than
i would like to see oh so y'all coming
around in my 1998 coming up i've been
telling y'all
i'm not going to say 1980s the idea is
98 we're going to put them before 98
i guess 10 years 10 years is a long time
a lot of stuff can happen in 10 years
exactly we've had all the wars ended ten
years yeah not that loaded though not
that not that good
it's not that bad it's not as bad as
like last gen destiny loading so that
co-op i can't press xbox live but it's
just i'm i'm gonna concede a lot of
things
because attic and i were jumping into
each other's world yeah tried to do it
with sinister and kaibatsu
somebody didn't put the proper
wording oh you had to call multiplayer
so we're standing there for a half an
hour
rob is trying to figure out
he invites me to the party i joined the
first thing i say is is the
capitalization
i had to make y'alls jojo
was correct oh the l is supposed to be
capitalized
yeah
and i'm the weakest dude oh
the more people you have there
the scaling is crazy on the ball no it's
it goes off level since he was starting
just starting the game and you were so
high level they put you closer to his
level than the other way it's correct
okay that's crap that's crap because i
got in there and i'm trying to beat the
center i'm like i beat the center by
myself what the hell is this and then it
it wasn't going down like that but as
soon as kybatsu fell out like because he
got murdered yeah so as soon as he got
murdered to the jets
my strength
[Laughter]
they let you lose yeah yeah so we got it
done and you know we got to we got to
play you know today because sin is just
having a good time no doubt waving our
dirty fingers in the air um
i got to talk to you know these these
frauds out there oh fraud alert what's
up
a lot of you dudes is out here capping
um
talking about okay what's going on it's
two games in particular what's happening
um
one there's gonna be a playstation or
both of them it's gonna be a place yeah
sometimes i feel slowly gonna catch a
bullet for some reason but let's let's
see no it has absolutely nothing to do
with sony okay it has everything to do
with microsoft oh that's the first let
me get three sit by gg for this one no
no but it's these dudes just out here
capping wrong
you know so these dude
let me see where where it is
all right
these dudes acting like the show came
out and and they're ridiculous
to me hold on with the show the baseball
game
let me get these super chats while
you're doing it
from donald talk who i owe sony's knees
for breath of the wild to delay
man he he hardcore about that breath of
the wild i'm with it though i'm with him
then we got um
we got a raid and blade with the 14
month chat
hello everyone it's that iop time i'm
happy that i got to mountaintop after i
got him
that one yeah and then we got the two
the 26 months uh chat from smittysmith
congratulations lords and chad the
legends smith
for sure and then we got a big mad bowl
with the 21 months uh chat uh he didn't
say nothing i didn't even know you could
like
reply with not saying anything what he
was saying was um i'm i'm right
um
all right what's up that's it okay so
all right crusader kings three oh you
playing too okay no no no i gotta i
gotta i gotta tell these dudes
first of all
millions of pc dudes love it yes
and what's not for you
that doesn't mean it's not for the next
one
[Music]
hating on somebody else's fun on to
something right i'm so sick and tired of
that like oh it's game pass fodder it is
not game password it's fodder for you
massive franchise on pc yes
and then it's tunic
if i catch any of you dudes out there
calling it a souls-like game
it's more like zelda like the whole
thing
it's zelda it's it's if zelda and star
fox had a baby
that's what that's the game like you got
the fox and you got the zelda skills
with the sword and shield
and so
you mean to tell me that souls is zelda
is souls like no it's not zelda came
first for any of these stupid souls
games so y'all are so quick to don't
throw that in your caption so quick to
cap oh it's a souls like game just
because the game seems hard to you
you don't if you haven't played a souls
game you have to understand that this
timing and stuff that goes into the
those games and his weight distribution
attic can talk more about that but the
zelda game that stuff is not prevalent
except for if you over incumbent in
certain games but
that is not tunic is a nice zelda-like
game so i'm tired of these frauds with
that oh it was a souls-like game okay
and they know who i'm talking about i'm
not going to do that
because people want to associate
anything hard with
souls like games for some reason yeah
sometimes it'd be that association a lot
i would say that on some level
like there's a game called moonlighters
that i think is like amazing and it's
more zelda like if people were trying to
say it was souls like mm-hmm
you okay they saying about your camera i
don't know if you could do anything on
the fly because they said you're
focusing a little crazy but if you can't
we're gonna have to fix that yeah we
gotta look for we get mad to be after
the show it's cool
all right cool cool so i'll be attending
getting like this
we're gonna just chat i'll do that
but
[Laughter]
so we don't see that because that is way
too much going on you're giving me some
guys energy right yeah that's some sauce
energy like that's crazy anyway get the
gave me the gym that should know me
little incognito spread that real estate
around with the iop now tell me what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to defining duke should be up
right now me and mr maddie play still
arguing about food and soda and all type
of stuff we do talk a little bit about
the camera playstation plus joint
still a little unfold like your
background better now but now you still
a little blurry oh okay hold on get you
we need you back to where you need to be
but um yeah man other than that i've
been rocking that we did that oh we got
a special one cooking with uh chris
raygun and ivantis it should be a witch
queen
spoiler cast that will be coming soon
it's already recorded into the decade
wait once colin released my album it's
good i'm just waiting for colin let my
record sales go
that day
[Music]
we had a good interview with um the
gentleman from uh i believe blue box
entertainment you know what's funny
i saw
colin post that and i was like i ain't
even watching that i know this dude
going dance around every conversation it
was i was like if there is nothing on
twitter that's maybe you think this dude
is going to be genuine or anything it
was very interesting you know what i'm
saying but y'all check that out kyle
colin put his album out first though
i can listen man the boy do double i
can't platinum artists you don't say i'm
on the label though
but anyway
yo i got that shout out to the last word
we eat batiste i got trash
i appreciate it man we have much it was
very spicy shout uh devotion we had that
we talk about from a player who have a
play destiny coming back to it we talked
a little bit of the playstation plus
mooch had a lot to say about the
playstation plus revamp we'll get about
that and uh for me king yeah i've been
playing crusaders kings three i've been
rocking that out and um
got to admit man it's very unique it's
more it's different than what i thought
it was but in a good way i like all of
the kick yo you gotta chill
come on man you can't fix it i don't fix
it don't like it now don't be doing all
that while i'm doing it
anyway it's a good game check it out i
get it but you got to be into it's more
about relationship your dynasty the lead
to people who you set up and position
you know what i'm saying and marrying
and stuff like that as well as warfare
and all that other stuff of course
that's the shot to the raid team last
night was getting on shout out to fork
boy gaming down with the destiny clan
salute you know what i'm saying salute
to him so you know what you got that
going on and then also playing a little
demo me and adam got some demo action
going on what's
okay
um shout out to uh
30 days of coach oh i see that you know
what happened it's oh y'all don't know
what it is it's in my mouth oh go
i hate him i hate him so much
now we get to chad anyway so you know
when you're when you're focusing like
that king all you have to do is like act
like you're taking a picture and it'll
go back to normal
yeah you know how many pitches i got in
there he's still off though addict like
don't he still look off yeah i got to
get the lab on that one but anyway
anyway so look we got that going on and
then um yeah i can say before for that
so okay i'll add it if you could get a
couple of super chats and then i'll set
some other things up
all right um
we have a
five dollar super chat from flame
when jim clown shoes ryan said we cannot
put our games day and day in the service
of that sacrificing quality it will be
the show said excuse me
we gotta find out super chat from smitty
smith how come ps plus is more like
minus
the hashtag x wow
we got a two dollar super chat from sith
lord
he said your cup is duke deku from my
hero academia
we got a five dollar supernatural from
somebody smith i a lord uh cognito
didn't
didn't the sony fanboys say they didn't
buy a console to play old games hashtag
booker x they're giving them a book of
ex-frankfurt shout outs
messy early
that that is the uh this is what you
have that is the the cup it's becca from
uh oh that's what it is okay yeah thank
you for my hero academy see look look
king this this is what you want you know
it's focusing on that
focusing on me that's what you see
focusing on that
focusing on me let's do it again
focusing on that focusing on me time on
camera talk it's focusing on the
important things in the background
you're not important no obviously the
camera doesn't think so
anyway so look y'all it is that time of
the month we gotta give some low love
what's going on ksi um
some love towards the gaming man log
ned's been in the building really been
killing it yo we got a tremendous team
man as i look it it just grows it gets
bigger and bigger the quality is getting
better and better and i'm very proud so
shout out to all the writers on the team
editorial shout out to mach mood our
editor-in-chief is ramadan right now so
send some love to him you know what i'm
saying while he's going call him a
boomer camera
somebody said king got bigger goggles i
was dying anyway but um yeah man we want
to salute that so it's that time of the
month where you know again recipes our
brother lord dizzy who kind of we came
up with this idea to kind of celebrate
each month one writer that went above
and beyond one writer that really did
his thing in the month of march
exceptional month he is king the lord of
the lords minute let's give him that you
know i'm saying he's definitely lost the
law's minute his segments on gaming
movie pop culture absolutely kill it he
has one of the most detailed destiny
valve disciple ray guys i've ever seen
is up now and um yeah man he's been
holding us down for a minute so i am
proud
to present the latest winner of the i
dizzy log net scribe of the month to
lord prince delos aka ty swenson what's
going on put your hands together now
he's supposed to make it i don't know if
he things got caught up but if he does
jump in to accept his word we'll give
him give him his word his bars for that
but he's been killing it man he's just
been that's my god yeah he was not
yo flames it was rigged he got it
because he had a positive destiny to
review listen
i told you what you got to do if you
want to win describe it but let me stop
i let me stay there ain't like that they
like that but
he had a fantastic advanced gg
yeah
hey he had he had a fantastic article
but his lawyers must have been lost
minutes have been absolutely killing it
so look to ty swanson hopefully he can
come in and get his reward launch the
game with that net entire team
absolutely
killing it so that's what i got there so
i want to get a couple of other uh super
chats
yeah
um let me
i think we only have one
we got a two dollar superstar from jd
gamer
good morning lords let us
in today's holy service
we got a five dollar super chat from
creeper
evo x
you got to join two media orca services
and we'll come up
short to game pass
oh that that's kind of that's kind of
true you know i actually said it on the
attic show that they combined those
services because they got tired
playstation now uh staining their
reputation oh my lord we got a two live
super driver for victor alex team salute
to you guys no doubt sheltered
praise the lords on their day looking
forward to king getting messy today hit
that like button i got something for you
baby
there you go now we can see where he got
it
i was touching it
there he go
i had to touch it and make sure that it
got me in focus
[Laughter]
anyway we all good to go now that's
what's up so look salute hopefully i can
say the talk comes through we'll give us
flowers let me get a speech off in the
middle cause we definitely want to
celebrate him you know what i'm saying
you already know but we will get into
these topics because um we got a lot
going on man we got a lot going on so uh
playstation plus revamped this is king's
topic i'll set it up for him um yeah man
playstation plus and playstation now
come together players can now choose
three flexible options and it's for the
playstation vlog right and he's got
basically talks about playstation plus
essential which is the same benefits
that um what you call it the initial
playstation plus members are getting
today two monthly downloadable games
exclusive discounts cloud storage for
save games online multiplayer access and
then we've got playstation plus
extra which provides all the benefits
from the essential tier adds catalog up
to
400 of the most enjoyable ps4 and ps5
games including blockbuster hits from
our playstation studios catalog and
third-party partners games in the extra
tier are downloadable for play and then
we've got excuse me that was also 15 a
month the prior tier was ten dollars a
month in the united states and then the
uh premium we have playstation plus
premium provides
all the benefits from essential and
extra tears and
adds up to 340 additional games
including ps3 games via cloud streaming
account a catalog of classic games
available in both streaming and download
options from the original playstation
ps2
and psp generations oh that's crazy
and then office cloud streaming where
playstation now is available customers
can stream games using ps4 and ps5
consoles and pc
and limited time limited game trials
will also be offered in this tier so
custom business i get demos too
you forgot you get discounts
yes you get discounts they're giving us
discounts oh my god shout out to big
clown gaming in the building no doubt
pulling up but uh let's get to a kick
this is your topic you want to talk
about this hello people
and today we are in class
what's going on you financial experts
out there all right let me get something
to
drink i like to say
uh that you know exactly what a good
deal is yes well let me show you exactly
what's really going on
under the hood of this new thing what's
going on and why you got some glasses
man what you guys are really paying for
okay
so let's go with the assumption that
sony
thinks you don't have enough money
and you're going to do the whole 18 for
12 months i want everyone to get out the
calculator
[Laughter]
so you go 18
times 12 yes
equals 216
bucks
right so you see that and you say oh my
god
216 bucks i can't do that i can't
actually live with this
sony said don't worry guys hold up king
let me let me let me do the math on mine
okay you're correct
[Laughter]
so sony says
hey guys
this is exactly what we will do to you
do for you
we can take that
and we can turn that into 120 bucks for
a year
oh my god
so serious sony
are you really going to drop down all
that money well let's see how much you
actually save so we're going to minus
120
out of that 216
right
and we're left with
96
that's the savings people
okay this is where you're saving at
right now
96 bucks sony is giving you sony's never
giving you anything
so you you saying that they're playing
oprah you save 96 you save 96. let me
show you let me show you what exactly
what they're doing what they're doing
this 96 is the actual cost
for the subscription service for the
year and that's the premium
now you divide that
by 12.
and it's actually worth eight bucks
that's the actual bottom line cause
sony's not giving you anything back you
see
they hope and they pray
that you can only survive on the 18 a
month and you you stretch it out for the
216 right
and if you do actually say you know what
i'ma do
the 120
i'm gonna get the year out the way right
minus out to 96 out of that
and they made 24 off for each and every
person that actually did that
now
there's no savings there's no deals
there's no bargains there's nothing
there and if you guys think that i'm
lying tell me the first day sony gave
you anything back
so let's break it really down
no one all you financial analysts i see
y'all all the time talking about oh sony
exists and everybody's they got a
million sales and
what is the breakdown the breakdown is
eight dollars is what it actually costs
sony's not gonna lose a penny so on each
yearly subscription for 120 they're
going to make 24 off of each you and for
every person that only pays
for that 18 a month you're paying for
two subscriptions and a half
they making money hand over fists
all right
we got we we've got the professor in the
building uh teaching us what's going on
here behind the scenes the analysts so
what's that kid got given off we're
substitute teacher energy but salute
man king you should feel ashamed
he didn't even give you full teacher no
i'm stealing
substitute
you just you you're just someone else's
side piece like you ain't even a full
page
i don't really operate in that school
like that
even when they unruly anyway so we got
mr big clown man yeah salute to you
brother cause um i wanted to shout you
out man you were really killing it the
interviews the growth i see the idea of
move
you outside man and we definitely
definitely it's been a minute since
you've been on so i definitely want to
give you flowers on that but uh good
timing next month oh all right no you
got more cooking i already know and um
we definitely talk about that but i
wanted to get you in here especially
this topic you know there's a lot going
on obviously the revamp of playstation
plus you know what's your thought
process to tears how you feeling about
it
well okay so
these tears oh
okay
it left you in tears
i guess
you stupid good
i wouldn't say it left me in tears uh
because we knew a lot of this has come
we talked about this so many times in
all of us and um
the thing that kind of just like first
of all you know we're talking about the
benefits out the gate right these are
some of the most basic bare bones
benefits i've ever seen but on top of
that
wasn't there supposed to be something
crucial added to this it's called
crunchyroll where's crunchyroll forgot
about the um
okay i do want to point out that when
they bought these these anime services i
was the first one to say you guys are
out of your mind if you think they
combine
[Laughter]
this is like a service that's very
limited in terms of options which you
the way you can experience majority of
these uh games the key behind game pass
and this type of service is nostalgia is
it not so you're going back and playing
those games downloading them so the fact
that you just the same way you left them
yeah you can't even play
no one
um you know even if they didn't offer
let's say what microsoft did where they
fine-tuned them and you get the um you
know the natural upgrades just where
like you get better performance and
whatnot it automatically upskills they
could add that later type of thing right
but i thought how much did that cost
when microsoft did that
and i forgot
free early
because it costs nothing
[Laughter]
but going back to it like when i looked
at what you're offering again you're
just not getting uh anything well you're
not getting the option to download these
games and then you know these are ps3
games some of your most key you know
games right are the playstation 3 games
your god of war threes you know in
general where's god of war three where's
why is that and people like to i said in
my video if you're like oh well you can
still download these games i'm like i
don't care about ps1 2 and you know and
vita i want the option to go back to ps3
i would love to play metal gear solid uh
four yeah you could not ps five
there's already there's already an
emulator that's very popular and this
was made by a small team a tiny team you
would think okay if that can be done by
a small team working in a basement type
of thing
and this is sony with all these uh
resources you mean tell me sony couldn't
have an option for you to download these
games or at least and drop that in the
software patch again i'm not talking
about trophy support that stuff could
have been coming later like like we got
with playstation network we got all that
stuff later they could have done that
with this service but you're asking 120
a year and again some people might be
going oh it's not that big deal i don't
really care about it 120 years you know
it's better than this because we got 700
games mind you
you can't even download all seven
yeah you're not you're not going to be
streaming the majority of these games on
this service yeah no it's it's not a gap
it's about it's a valid uh valid point
then it gets weird though the middle
tier is the one that's the most
insulting one you get ps4 and five in in
these two these are the ones that
introduce the ps4 and file library now
you guys remember if you buy the ps5
outright if you bought the ps5 you get
access to that little collection it's
like 20 games it's uh ps4 thousands that
were like quote-unquote enhanced for ps5
yeah um
what's happening to that list
is gonna move that list to the hundred
dollars the point where they're gonna
add on to it i doubt they're gonna add
on to it but if that list is still there
let's see how deadly still there and we
go to this hundred dollar tier um what
does that leave some of the empty spots
for these games are they going to
include those games at 100 because keep
in mind there's um they you know there's
a lot of games that obviously
we're not going to get yet right because
they just dropped like um we're not
going to get
we're not going to get like
jesus christ was there's a few horizons
gt7 we're not going to get those yet i
can see those games this is where this
little caveat kind of and i have this
whole theory for um because y'all notice
the little window got significantly less
when it comes to games going to pc i can
see this dropping the six months now
with this service included where you can
you know they'll do that every six
months after the game's release you know
when they when the game's stagnant in
the market it's got what they think they
can get they'll drop it in the service
you can play it there and then that will
be obviously a part of pc as well guys
you can have that be uh with it as well
real quick not to side divert because we
got a lot of stuff going on we got ran i
thought i jumped in the building
hustling motivating jump to the building
but before i do all that someone missed
they call for their speech
[Laughter]
it's not his fault because i did tell
him 1 30 and we were actually earlier
because song wasn't hit so real quick i
just have to let the man get his balls
off log next scribe of the month for
march my man todd switzer aka prince
delos speech brother speech
all right what's how's it going everyone
i'm not going to keep y'all for long but
uh yeah i was super surprised that um
getting subscriber of the month for
march i loved it i was like
why you didn't get it sooner no longer
well technically he was cold winner one
time but this is i know i wanted his
solo
solo album okay
baby yeah my my partner they're the um
ultimate cheerleader in my corner
they're always like yo your writing is
great the stuff that you do
is wonderful you give yourself more
credit you plug when you're out in the
streets yeah um
but yeah uh i did a lot of destiny
content leading up to getting scribe of
the month or destiny to the witch queen
the key defeated guy
and yeah
i just love writing what i'm passionate
about whether it be games i'm playing
whether it be shining light on diversity
and social issues going on in the
industry
um doing lloyd's man with king is always
a pleasure oh for people who might be
looking for
you know extra content that might not be
happening on ilp sundays check out the
lord's minute with me april whoever else
is doing it yeah we have a
broad uh horizon of topics that we cover
uh whether it be comics tv shows games
um critical things happening in the
industry lawyers manager is the place to
check it out at um yeah i just love the
team i love working at lordsofgaming.net
i love working with everything on the
iron lords and um absolute to the
warlock delegation all right no we'll
like stand up you already know you was
it you was it off the rip
now we know how you going
hold on we don't listen salute to utah
you've been absolutely killing your
enthusiasm your passion for the industry
absolutely outstanding the the the
connection you have with king on those
topics with just everything in pop
culture i love i love when you scoop me
up for any any destiny talk you know i'm
always for that and just in general it's
just been a pleasure to work with you to
see your star shine salute the whole
team was behind it mahmoud almost
unanimous this month like you really
killed it and you're holding this down
so salute to the march scribe of the mom
todd swinson you already know make sure
you hit up solve in the dm get yourself
whatever you want you already know you
killed it brother and we will be talking
some more in the future
yeah we'll do y'all have a great show
i'm going to go put in my time at the
gym oh you already know
but did you do that did you did you
focus did you energy what'd you do that
new shaker came out
[Laughter]
and i think we're going to have to
intervene man there's too much
compromise going on over here
we've been covered
can't get caught it's looking like cogs
literally got a discord server this says
you gonna listen to me right now
[Music]
but i see some guests done pulled up to
help us out with the topic and solved
our beer first let's talk about the band
with the million rand outdoor 19 how are
you doing sir
i'm doing good uh
um
the man with no camera
stop it
[Laughter]
the man the man videos stop it
[Music]
the man with no heater
what i do is you know for spaces see we
wouldn't know if you butt naked or not
i very well could be king
oh
don't be coming
[Laughter]
a little bit of xbox too
always killing you and jazz and of
course the videos but yeah man what's
going on playstation plus
re-vamp man how you feeling about this
you know obviously there's talk of
whether or not it's a competitor whether
it's not a competitor that's another bit
of talk so wherever you want to go with
this as far as your thoughts
uh wherever i want to go well first off
i didn't even know i was going to be on
the show until what 20 minutes ago that
is correct
you're like hey can you come on and i'm
like i suppose i could come on i wasn't
doing anything uh-huh he said you did
dmv before preemptively somebody said
yeah i dm'd but i dm'd you because i
wanted to show you something you guys
can laugh about it yes utterly
ridiculous yes well what i saw was so i
was like i gotta have a good laugh about
this and he's like hey can you come on a
little bit talk about some stuff and i'm
like well i gotta have that voice but i
asked you why can't it be like yo you're
my man since you're awake
give him the voice all you want
i know we go long so what i know you got
things you got to do so if you can only
jump in for a bit yeah you know
it's it's five hours of sitting here you
know all naked is not you know very
conducive
actually you
ran you sitting there all night
but what ran it sounds so comfortable
[Music]
what the what is going on what is
happening what's that red let's start
with the time the show went left
continue the show went left uh so
yeah i mean playstation plus is all
right i mean the new revamp it's nothing
spectacular it's
exactly what everybody said it was going
to be them combining a failed service
into an actual pretty good service well
uh at least a very popular service right
yes um
i find it odd that time limited demos
are on the highest tier like it almost
seems to me that the highest tier is
incomplete yeah
all it is
right and
i think i said it on xbox two or at
least when i first saw it i was like you
know
i think at some point in the future that
is where first party game date
playstation games will go they'll go
into the
premium
tier which they can then rename
uh you know playstation day one or
something right for
18 minutes
are you impressed that day one day and
date is still happening because i don't
believe anything jim ryan says
jim bryant said that it's not
he feels he's in a good virtuous cycle
he also
but then he also literally says at the
end of it like i don't know what the
future's gonna hold guys exactly he
didn't say that but he did say he said
the way the world is changing so very
quickly at the moment nothing is forever
he said who would have said
what has sony done with the generations
though they've changed what the
generation
and they did say they don't like old
games and they got it
again
you're highlighted
the biggest question is called do you
believe jim ryan what he's saying
no
i don't that is true that you got me
there we don't need to go anywhere no
but i i i have to ask the question but
anyway back to red like you were saying
it's it's very telling to me at least
that
all the pr that came out of jim ryan the
day they announced it was about what the
service wasn't doing
rather than what the service was doing
like
no talk of like you know what games
you're gonna have at launch for the
second tier like the immediate response
was
we're not putting our games day one in
his escape your subscription service
that's kind of like netflix coming out
and being like you're not getting star
wars movies on here or marvel stuff like
you don't tell customers at least you
don't start telling off customers what
you're not going to do
right
um
but i mostly think that's just that's
just pr they needed a way to kind of
get out to the fans about why they're
not doing something and it plays into
sony's overall pr that they're a their
games are
magnificent right and that their games
require so much money to make
sense
and that if they don't put that money
into these games then god award the next
god of wars
it's gonna be it's not going to be any
good and the playstation fans eat it all
up just like they ate up the whole
we believe in generations bull right i
didn't swear they're cog thank you i
appreciate you what a view so no i don't
believe a word he says and when he talks
about
live uh you know um live service games
because it was very much like
oh we think live service games are the
future we don't think game subscriptions
are the future but it's like well who
said game subscriptions were the future
phil's never said that
bill always said like game pass is one
aspect
of what we do at xbox okay and that live
service sort of is has been the future
for some time now it's that finally
sony's like jumping on the bandwagon
but to me like when you got what haven's
making and you got probably whatever
uh deviation games is making
those games are going to be live service
games and in today's environment live
service games need to be one of two
things they either need to be free to
play
or they need to be in a subscription
service and they also probably need to
be day one on pc
if you're trying to get the biggest
audience possible to play it you know to
spend all the micro transactions so in
my view
if you're not going to do free to play
with haven's game
then haven's game is going to be in a
subscription service that you also have
a third tier for which you can
conveniently
then kind of change the narrative saying
like well we did say you know when we we
weren't going to do this but we said oh
things change right but
i mean the service i don't know the
service basically is just like
hey we got rid of a service that was a
complete failure
and we've built it into a yeah
playstation i was complete abject
failure by every stretch of performance
metrics sony barely talked about it for
years
and they rolled it into their most you
know obviously successful subscription
service so it makes a lot of sense
sony's gonna basically use this
opportunity to um
help or not help them get more revenue
because they're going to have start
having users who were normally
accustomed to paying 60 a year or 10 a
month to now paying
100 a year instead of 60 so it's a way
to make more revenue
you missed that part professor king did
it so it's a way for them to get more
revenue from their existing user base
um let me ask you this before before we
pass it off because you've also said
something you've been very starch on
the day and date thing and you probably
wanted a few cause i know we talked
offline and then all you actually said
on xbox too which is you feel that they
will eventually go day and day
and like so so what makes you think
because i guess to play devil's advocate
my feeling is like well maybe because
the model that they currently have is
working from them as far as you know
them not really putting their games in
there you know obviously the 79 price
point they don't really it's not really
too much pushback consumer-wise because
games are still selling right so my
question or you know to you would be
like you know what's to stop them from
staying you know status quo or staying
sta pat as opposed to copying the
microsoft you don't play well i never
said they would put all their games day
and day i said i think there's i think
there's
like
their live service stuff is going to
have to be either they're going to have
to be they're going to be free to play
okay you know um
microsoft is obviously one for the
different approach where they're all in
on hey this is how we're gonna grow our
service and we're gonna use star fields
and the call of duty's of the world
presumably to grow that but
um
maybe you can make the argument that a
single player game isn't maybe
something best for a subscription
service
but uh
we know for a fact from our buddy jim
ryan himself well even from the
investors uh that sony has what a big
cloud do you know this how many how many
games 10
i mean we're in an era right now that
people don't want to pay for multiplayer
at least the expectation
from gamers is that multiplayer should
be free these days
and the biggest games are so if you're
gonna try to come out with the live
service game
uh
you can't be 70 bucks
i mean we we battlefield 2042 just came
out and what is it how many months now
four months five months and is
completely dead in the water i mean yeah
it was a bad game but also
in the air are free to play you can't
come out as a full price game and i'm
sorry like
no matter how good haven's game is going
to be your
deviation games or any of those other
ones they're going to fail as a live
service at 70 bucks
so either it's going to be free
or it's going to be in a subscription
service so my guess is the third tier
the tier that make doesn't make them any
sense with
time limited demos and backwards
compatibility
like that'll be the tier that will
suddenly be like hey if you want to play
this stuff it's in this so you think
that's what you involved is i'm sorry
and that's where sony will then get more
money out of the user base and that's
will actually get more subscribers like
new subscribers because that's the tier
they'll subscribe to to play those games
that's how i feel to go in the future
fair enough we got two other guests we
got to get their opinion we got the lord
of virtual legality and double duty on
the bitcast
barbad
business law firm let me check your
level sir how are you doing sir
yes please do check my levels i never
know if you can hear me no no you're
into one of these no no you're great
right now yeah absolutely fantastic and
thank you for for pulling up man so look
playstation plus revamp you know what
are your thoughts on this whole thing
and obviously jim ryan's comments about
you know not basically saying that their
title is virtuous and they don't choose
to put those day a day and mimic a game
pass-like model
well before i give my thoughts i think i
should qualify them by saying i do like
sony and playstation but i cover them in
the way that i do because i think
they've been making messaging errors for
a good couple months now and i think
this is the latest in a fairly long line
of them
um i think that they make a fundamental
mistake by competing with game pass but
not really competing with them this is
essentially like dollar store discount
game pass that doesn't really
necessarily offer you what their closest
competitor is doing so they can check a
box as to what services they're
providing i think you can tell from jim
ryan's interviews that they don't really
believe in it they don't really
understand why people would want to play
retro games or these kinds of things
and so they have constructed something
that allows them to potentially upsell
their existing playstation plus people
much like you'd get to at a retail
counter when somebody tries to sell you
a strategy guide with that game that
you're buying and otherwise aren't
really thinking about
what that looks like because as they've
said they don't think that they can use
their own current monetization
strategies uh with a day and date or
other ways to use a game pass type
library
so to me i read all that and i say you
don't your heart's not in this right so
you're doing it for a different reason
and as a sony playstation player i look
at it as fairly disappointing when you
tell me okay it's going to be eternal
it's going to be god of war 2018 it's
gonna be spider-man it's gonna be
spider-man
miles morales it's gonna be mortal
kombat
somebody who is invested in the
playstation ecosystem says okay
the ones that aren't five years old are
all games that i already own because
i've been supporting your ecosystem so
it's not for me right so what are we
talking about here now some part of this
has to be based on the value that we
will see when we get a chance to look at
the libraries right um is premium just
the playstation
now service strapped on to the end is
there more effort being put into
whatever the library at extra is
we don't know but i think everything
that you've seen so far gives you reason
to doubt and unfortunately i've said
this before in this space but i think
playstation needs to get weird they need
to do wild things they need to do
different things that aren't just
discount versions of what their
competitors are doing because they can't
aim the money canon they don't have the
infrastructural resources that a
microsoft does and microsoft the benefit
of the community is spending those
resources
but
sony if we want them to survive and
thrive and i do
should be looking at things that aren't
just well that looks like game pass but
worse right that's my overall thing let
me ask you real quick because you said
something very interesting to be getting
a statement in the sense of you know
almost like a half-hearted attempt kind
of thing as a competitor but there has
been talk online that i've seen and
people like oh no this is not a
competitor so for like based on your
thoughts like because i even seen an
article i believe shout out to uh pc mag
and they asked jim ryan specifically in
an interview they were like hey like how
was how this was way before and it was
asking like how he would respond how
sony would respond to microsoft game
pass and he said um nothing was
expecting he said they weren't expecting
anything to do anything at the time but
he says there's actually news to come
but just not today so the direct
response to the question of do we have a
competitor was yes there's news to come
just not today
so the way i interpret it and correct me
if i'm rojo is that on some level
internally they are viewing it as
competitive am i wrong to assume now
what do you think no i don't think you
can look at what they just released and
say that has nothing to do with game
pass right i think that they like that
stance that says we're not competing
with them because if you are
you're losing like the the it's not it's
not equivalent so you don't want to be
competing with them this is why i would
have said get weird instead of doing
anything that looks like this have a
library of vr games that will be
exclusively playstation 2
something that microsoft isn't going to
match that isn't discount microsoft
because what happened regardless of how
they want you to think about it oh we're
not competing this isn't a game pass
service you know what happened this week
which is game spot puts out a graphic
that shows the differences ign puts out
a graphic everybody talks about them as
if they are competitors and you're not
dumb jim ryan you're not dumb sony you
know this is how this industry is going
to look at these kinds of things so why
did you structure it this way that's
that's the fundamental problem i have
with it is you could have done something
different you said we're going to get
you libraries of games from your
favorite playstations something that
feels different so that you don't have
that obvious comparison point and by
giving us that obvious comparison point
it seems like a shallow competitive
behavior so i think they made a mistake
there and
that interview and i've been listening
to you a little bit before i started
talking
the way it's been characterized is right
they don't feel like they want to do
this so much there's a lot of backing
from jim ryan are you saying that
they're being forced to do this
i'm saying about that you can read
between the lines of his interview and
you can feel the friction at the various
sie board rooms or sony board rooms
depending on how high up it goes
in the quote that he gives about pc
games that there was clearly some kind
of fighting about whether that made
sense
four years ago we could put pc gaming
out you can feel all of this jim ryan
has a quote that says effectively i
don't know who would buy premiere this
doesn't seem attractive to anybody yeah
he kind of
we'll put it out there like he doesn't
agree necessarily with what the company
is doing and then by the time you get
the end of his interview he's basically
saying well
aren't live services subscriptions it's
like no what are you talking about but
but but you can see that the push for
sony is going to be live services and
that this is well we've got a game pass
too it's the internet meme right right
right i won't game fast you guys can
pass it home playstation plus extra
he said at home you're funny let's get
let's get let's get motivated man once
you heard the uh playstation plus revamp
man what are your thoughts about like
what where are you at with it and um we
already touched a competitive thing but
just in general personally for you is it
something that you're interested in any
of the tiers or anything like that
uh i would be if the playstation 3 games
were downloadable apparently you can
only stream those um i'll be in my retro
bag as of late as you all know as you
all may know um
but this service isn't good man like a
lot of things are are off here like who
would pay first of all i want to take
y'all back to 1994 playstation was the
first ones that i remember but who came
with like a package demo this like if
you couldn't afford the game and a lot
of them yes that's what you had to play
and they gave it to you for nothing
right
in fact you got a lot of times going
like this
to the price but yeah well still
regardless you got it day one now
they're charging you for demos and
people talk about how long it takes to
make a game like don't they add like
three or four months when you make a
demo on top of the game that you're
already making all right so i ain't
really trying to hear that and they go
why are you paying 18
for a service that i i know y'all said
it wasn't in competition with game pass
but let's be real dawg it is like we're
gonna be real it is this wouldn't have
been a move because this was already
playstation now anyway like nobody
wanted a playstation now so this is
this is definitely in competition and as
far as the retro games um one of the
things that xbox does over a playstation
is that
where is it where is it hold on give me
a minute oh okay i can pop this
up
yup it'll play not only will it play
it'll play like the new updated version
720p version of this game too and my
xbox one x by the way so we ain't even
talking about the series stuff but then
the one x this will play so i mean
there's a lot that's that's wrong with
what's going on um somebody said do you
believe jim ryan no that boy be
flip-flopping boy that boy
look he's grabbing like two eggs on a
sunday morning
how many times that man that went back
on his word
but i mean the information that he's
given you is on a need to know basis and
you don't need to know
you're
how are you going to save you know how
are you going to save your games in the
cloud if if you don't subscribe to one
of these services how about they make
you pay for that oh coincidentally
that's how i actually discounts hustle
oh oh how about that that's actually how
i lost the same foul to persona 5 the
vanilla version yeah i didn't i didn't
have any clown and i've lost that save
file three times yeah um
look i don't know about none of this man
i i just think that um
the playstation look crazy right now um
it's getting it's getting bad not like
playstation i want i want to see the
next uncharted man and i want to see all
these things move forward but what's the
point of you even putting this service
out if you're not going to match the
competition dog if you're not going to
put games day and date in there like
what's the they don't have to match the
competition if the competition tells you
they like to spend seventy dollars
okay well i don't like to spend seventy
dollars
sir my stomach is touching my back
for ten dollars a month like these that
got on pc dawg are you trying that's
what i said man six months i could see
six months drop off for these games and
yeah so let me let me ask you before i
open it up to addict and lawyers
big cloud or whole on this like the the
fi the vibe i'm getting from you is that
they they don't seem
fully
wholeheartedly invested in it right
there's there seems to be some type of
internal conflict so
what could it be good what do you think
is going on that's that's pushing them
outside their comfort zone their
approach for this is exactly their
approach to how their stuff with pc
started remember
pc i i said on this show back in 2019
that i knew for a fact that sony was
going to be putting their games on p and
i said horizon was going to come the
playstation community
you were still intimately yeah disagreed
with me and attacked me even though i
had like
i had like 13 sources on that so i knew
it was coming right right but if you
remember how sony when they first
announced that game for pc
herman hulse was like it's just one game
we're not bringing all of our games yeah
everything is coming right so to me this
is just
basically sony
trying to take their customers taking
their super hardcore fans by the hand as
they lead them slowly step by step
through the process at first it's just
one triple a game come to pc
and then it's almost all of them and
then oh well it was three years but now
it's going to be six months to a year
and then eventually it's going to be day
and dates right and now it's like don't
worry guys you know we we
we're making the games that you want
we're we're investing the virtuous cycle
and all that stupid nonsense you know
quality
but at the same time the future could
change and then in two to three years
from now when all these games show up in
the subscription service i mean jim ryan
even said
in the article that with regards to the
pc stuff that people had made their
piece with it and nobody cares anymore
wow he literally said that and i'm like
jim
that's not the case because i still see
playstation fans being super upset about
that but yeah time does heal time does
see all wounds remember corey tory
barlock was like the biggest advocate
for putting god of war on pc and i will
say the comparison
you know we don't know the library but
you know microsoft
and i don't know if there's a topic or
not but let's go the comparison is going
to even look worse yeah an xbox game
past family player
intervention because like you have
people comparing the libraries people
pairing the prices well what are we
people going to say when you can get
xbox game pass ultimate for
thirty dollars a month for five of your
friends
they ran instead of you know i'm just
saying it's going to even look worse in
the future ran i got a question
why do you think that that service is
launching in june
uh i don't know i got an answer
yes kayla launched in june sir
um because mlb the show is launching the
game pass
so you can't launch your service and
don't have your first party game there
and it's in the competitor's
service
please so in order not to look bad
we'll launch in june that game will come
out there and then we're going to make
money over here
and then maybe it might be inside their
service done i doubt it very seriously
but
well i wonder the comparisons will be
too high
if it launched earlier and that game
isn't in their own service
well i also want they never did put
correct me if i'm wrong and maybe big
cloud you know this they never put mlb
21 into their into ps9 or ps plus did
they no i don't think so it could very
much be a situation where microsoft
has the rights to that game in a
subscription service and sony can't put
that put their game into it
you know like kind of like uh
it could be something like that because
you'd imagine they want to do that but
yeah i would say when whenever uh the
the game the family plan comes out
they're just gonna add another thing to
those ign game spot
uh lists where it's like you know what's
the better value i can get all these
games day one plus these third party
games
and for barely more than what it costs
if the high highest tier playstation
plus i can bring four of my friends with
me
i mean
you know that's it's gonna be you
haven't even gotten to the big releases
yet from the first party
that is true that's true
yeah no that's true a valid point i see
added jump down for a second so we'll
keep it pushing here oh okay i didn't
see your thing i saw your bike muted but
um yeah man what you think man
playstation plus revamp where you at
all right first off i want to point out
is
that all this
if you really look at it you strip down
these these tiers
what is this playstation plus plus
that's what i'm calling playstation plus
plus what is this really
tier one is what you've been paying for
for playstation plus which is 9.99 uh
how much is playstation now currently
9.99 yeah
and
it feels like to me
for the most part they split up
playstation now
put it in two tiers and they're trying
to charge you more for that service
because currently
you could play playstation 3 games
on playstation now is that correct i
don't know i don't use these stuff
games so so currently
currently you could download ps4 ps5
games onto your playstation and play it
locally is that right big click cloud
yeah not dude now
now did i just name two different tiers
continue adding i know what you're going
to
they have found a
really sleazy unique way
of making you pay more
for the same wax service they had two
months ago
i like that sleep
what about you don't have you don't see
perceived value in the premium tier with
the um
the only value to this is not having oh
buckle jesus jesus what about the
savings addict what about the you know
it's 216. what savings that
king if you want to play 360 games xbox
one games what do you got to do i just
got to pop it in
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
did you read his quotes he's like mrs
four
that's what he says he was under the
wrestling man
turn your mic level up just slightly
slightly i'm sorry
just a little bit now you went to low a
little bit yeah
i can yell louder no there you go
um
yeah so he doesn't believe in it but you
look at the tears anyway it's
the thing that's most offensive to me on
that is you put the retro the most retro
stuff at the you have to buy everything
else tier
it's just a wild thing this is why i
said they should have gone with
libraries or something different because
all they really did was strap now to
playstation plus
and their big genius ideas are annual uh
so that they can try to get people in
for a longer subscription revenue term
which is fine yeah that's normal
economics and xbox doesn't offer an
alternative for that yet right now
correct correct um and so that's one of
their big moves but when you as the ceo
come out and say i premiere i'm sure
somebody would want retro games we don't
understand any of this backwards
compatibility stuff so we slapped it all
at the end
um oh it feels bad definitely
i feel like the biggest reason they're
doing this
is because how bad playstation now kind
of looked in terms of like metric wise
like
output they had like three million subs
for like 15 years
i i feel like you know they're like look
game pass
is is definitely destroying that
subscription service
but if we combined it with playstation
plus
we we go above it so now instead of
saying playstation now is equal to game
pass
it has like drastically lower you know
uh ratings and subscription counts
now we could say that our subscription
service has more mm-hmm but it doesn't
matter if there's two other tiers aren't
you supposed to do that with uh xbox
live uh games with gold uh see but
aren't you supposed to add that to that
and you know what's funny what bang
people are trying to sit there and
they're trying to say but at it
they they're giving you the ability to
be able to download these and you have
access to the online features on
playstation hey idiots you already have
online features on any game on
playstation now is that true or false
big cloud
gonna be like either fishing rep
right i'll hit my bed
are you guys always doing cross-examine
this stuff
always does it though
i love it
look at this it just feels like state
property to me it just feel like get
down to lay down that's what's saying
stop
all this is
is
messy all this is
is preparation for the future oh okay uh
they they know
not necessarily grim i feel like we
shouldn't you like putting grooming oh
my god
i'm just saying
playstation knows that
right now they're fine right but they
don't know what the future holds for
them
guarantee every game is going to do
the numbers they think they're tomorrow
it might be inside there you might get
god of war inside there if it don't sell
in june
that equals your doom ridiculous anyway
let me jump you know i always said ilp
is one of the best xbox podcasts oh my
god
[Music]
so pretty much i i feel like what
they're doing
is they're like look like
we spent a lot of money on playstation
now so we're we're going to
split it which you know i do think this
format's better than playstation now
being by itself korea because i don't
think playstation i was ever going to do
anything by itself
they've always supported playstation
plus over playstation now you see more
day and day games going in playstation
plus this is the better choice to do but
it's just like you could have made
different things that's why i feel like
they're like look we're gonna get some
heat for this right but we're gonna make
i feel like there was originally
supposed to be two and they made that
third tier so they can slide in those
day and date games down the line
because if you look at it like oh
i think fundamentally what you see in
this approach is that again you can you
can feel this in the interview that
there are boardroom fights about this
sony rightly or wrongly truly believes
as best i can tell that it is not
sustainable to do what xbox is doing
right they are subsidizing that process
that they're in the user acquisition
phase that it doesn't make sense long
term so what i view this is as a
temporary measure that puts that checks
box on sony's side of things they can
continue to sell their boxes under
televisions and they're waiting xbox out
because they don't think it works
literally now i tend to think they're
wrong but this is a reasonable minds can
differ kind of feel they're projecting
out into the future and microsoft to
their credit keeps saying it's doing all
these things it's advancing all these
aspects of the industry it is not
sharing direct game pass numbers that is
sure
inputs and outputs it's not telling you
exactly what's happening there got a
question you can tell sony has analyzed
this and they've talked to their
financial folks and they know what their
roi is on their games which without a
game pass kind of concept we're
generally selling better than
microsoft's best first party games
without that subscription so
just hold on hold on i got a question
because i'm gonna forget but my question
for hulk is if that is the case right
and i do believe a lot of what you're
saying my question is why
it's almost the thought process if
you're the leader and you're sustaining
finance you have all this financial
revenue doing what you're doing why copy
the third place guy why copy a model
that you yourself don't even believe in
what like if you're the leader why even
do that that's my only thing i'm just
curious of why even
put yourself in this position because
clearly the message that you're sending
i mean not you but you know the sony is
that they don't want to do this so like
you're fine right so stay away from that
they don't believe game pass day and
date works i i think you know this is
all speculation
yeah from the outside they don't think
game pass works but they also have a
somewhat broken product that they had
with playstation now which is mostly
broken because everybody thought of it
as a streaming service which is what it
was then they strapped a library to it i
don't really think that message got out
so much right so they're instead
highlighting the fact here that there's
a library with playstation now which is
what that extra tier is
and they don't believe it'll work but
they can see a way and this is probably
how it was sold internally that they
could upsell playstation plus well
that's a few more bucks if you want to
get access to library you're already
paying for multiplayer hell you're
already paying for cloud services you
chumps
cloud savings you're gonna pay for it
damn i think what it is so so they're
looking at it like that and then also i
think the preparation for the future is
correct though if it doesn't go the way
that they think and microsoft actually
can work this and i think sony's
thinking like i'm going to adaptable ads
that price at some point it probably is
being effectively subsidized by the rest
of the company and things like that if
it's going to work then they can slide
into that that's why you get jim ryan
being weird he has a very definitive
statement that says we're not doing that
and then in the next paragraph it's we
we might do that
i don't know yeah sure that's uh i'll
figure it out so it's to me it's it's a
it's a company that says well it's fine
if we're just upselling playstation plus
that could work out for us it's not a
strong committal thing right and maybe
maybe xbox is right you're trying to be
prepared either direction right i think
institutionally they think it doesn't
work in particular they think it doesn't
work if they can sell 13 million copies
of spider-man without you being
subscribed for it right okay back to
that i do
i do think that
they are progressing and it's not like
i do think that there is a realm where
they do do gay day games day and day and
the only time that that would i would
see happen is if the value overseas the
value of game pass makes them start
losing enough market share that's
overlooking their games because like
they make market shifting they're
worried about the market changing right
xbox if you want to tell this story xbox
in the last generation said we're losing
we're losing at this game of basketball
we're going to play football instead
right
we make it
as well we're old in basketball we're
dominating it basketball uh we don't
really want to play football but we'll
start a flag football intramural yo
we're going to be flag football in the
mural you ain't even hitting with the
high school interview come on let's be
real
they changed the ball there's no other
team playing they're playing basketball
for football but they don't like
football they said they don't feel
football is the future
microsoft stood up and said we don't
care what you don't like they're worried
that they're the mlb right which was
with the show released they're worried
that they're baseball and the nfl is
coming up yes that's what they're
worried about okay so they're going to
start saying what does the nfl look like
i got a question for you hogue yeah you
know
you mentioned like jim ryan and his talk
about um
the games as a service being the future
right
how do you view them the haven and the
bungie and the deviation games when
those games come out in a couple years
do you see them as full price 70
releases or
are they gonna have to be day one on pc
as well free to play or part of
subscription like do you think a full
priced
new ip is going to actually succeed in
the market as it is right now well a
couple of things one because they
apparently got bent over something when
they were negotiating with bungie they
won't control those
say that again
i think bungie wants to be free to play
with expansion add-ons kind of thing
like they would stream what they work
destiny into right
haven is a wild purchase because haven
hasn't done anything haven't 12 months
old
without from releasing anything i got
travis said it was a
in the market and they're grabbing
things that they think are interesting
before they would otherwise do so
in terms of the release of that game
we're guessing what that is we know it's
live services we know it's something
multiplayer so i think it would really
depend on the model that they're
building out there if it's going to be
free to play and monetization i think
you'd slap it in to some kind of bonus
tier of a subscription service but if
it's free to play anyway i mean what are
you really getting from that nobody
how do you feel about factions so cause
you know we're still waiting for we're
gonna pay for that two on that
now i'm one of the best ones of us last
of us yeah they're doing the remake of
the first one and we still haven't
gotten it i can honestly say i have no
idea what's going on with the management
of naughty dog in basically any respects
at this point um you know they're
remaking a game that is all of
seven years old
for the second time um so i i don't know
what kind of resources they're putting
in i think if sony is thinking about it
they'd make it a live services they'd
make it a multiplayer but they're also
probably watching halo infinite
really really really struggle with
keeping up with community expectations
are at the time the reason they bought
bungie is not destiny right they don't
have anything for their expertise for
the expertise yeah it's to help them out
with economics yeah go get them a handle
on the actual record to maintain the
full scale absolutely what the live
services looks like so
if they're thinking properly the
industry would support fractions best i
think as a free to play with a battle
pass and some monetization elements
right we know now watching gran turismo
seven watching them buying up live
services companies they don't have any
idea how to properly interact with that
market and they're smart enough let's
give sony's that's what i tell people
bringing
yeah the thing that we got to remember
too is
when it comes to the subscription
service i feel like they were they
weren't pressing the gas either one with
it because they knew they were wanting
to do something with both of them
individually
with some kind of future of the merging
i'm curious if they amp up supporting
both services together now so you know
they they might do that you i don't
think their games are coming day and day
you might have some indie games that
they support because they've done that
with you know uh the uh the car game
whatever that thing's called they've
done a couple games putting it to day
and date so i'm curious now since it's
done and over and it's merged i'm
curious if they're going to actually put
money behind the service now or they're
just going to literally keep it exactly
how it was but now it's together yeah
it's interesting we do have to hold up
on the value proposition to see what
those libraries actually look like i
agree we do agree i'll jump in and you
know everyone made a fantastic point
randy on fire you know every everybody's
been on fire and here's the thing
as it's currently constructed i i have
you know interested in what's going on
here you know i'm going to stay at my
current
middle tier which i'm apparently rolled
into
and
you know and i'm gonna stay there you
know my thing is i'm a huge ps1 fan i'm
a huge vita fan you know those videos
not listed playstation one vita yeah
that's behind
the commission a mission that's my heart
i really love you that like no
disrespect to switch i'm switching gang
all day but vita was
the worst part called
the lack of transparency about what's
doing this
not even an example is there like ps1
ps2 and ps3
and more updates to comment and the
thing to me that's just weird is is that
like i'm not a person just don't throw
numbers at me we have over four hundred
but that's what the fan base uses
i get that i get that 400 700 and kudos
to them
for knowing their base and i said this
on defining dude because they know that
their base where they use terms like
virtuous and our games are quality we
don't know if if putting our games in
this service is really to our advantage
because they know their fan base buys
into that right and that's how you start
to get over it
i call it the griezing it's the setup
yes was any of their games in a service
last year when they didn't reach uh dif
didn't um meet the
what metacritic uh publisher of the year
standard
i see what you're going to do
because right now the standpoint and
they have every right to make that
statement like look the reason our games
aren't in subscription service because
we have quality until we start seeing
more quality come out of game pass
because then once you see a lot of
quality come at game pass you're going
to have a different conversation look
sony over here is is saying this but
microsoft's proved to them otherwise
right and i i do i agree with hogg in a
sense it's it's hedging the bet for the
future they like the model where they
currently are they're not willing to
over commit it's almost a half dip your
toe in let's see
right let's do something that's very
advantageous for us financially
and that's fine you know for me
personally what i like with the service
before it revamped was in big cloud you
could help me out here is the
playstation collection i thought the
playstation collection was very positive
at the launch of the ps5 and i'm like
okay we got got a war in here you know
you got all your legacy titles so to me
what i would like it to evolve into is
you know whether it's we know now
shout out to nexus king's favorite
that's his heart but you know we know
now that they they're doing the pc thing
right which rand got stoned on iop for
saying that rand was the first that
people told him it never happened sorry
ryan sorry ran you you definitely
definitely i learned better to keep my
mouth shut all the things i do know that
i will not well i actually tell cockneal
some of the stuff i do know bro you
definitely carried across that wood it
got beat pelted up it was it was crazy
and to see it all transpired the way it
was it's very interesting so to me it's
now that we know the pc thing is coming
he's even openly admitted it he because
when he talked about that they say look
who would have thought we to put our
stuff in pc you know jim ryan said and
now and now it's coming so i think
would be cool i don't know if they're
gonna do it is if after the pc window
happens
when the the the zeitgeist of the
blockbuster goes down let's let's use
goes to ship in one of my favorite games
right
so when the pc release now comes because
we know it's coming right
yeah right you get that you get that
money on the back end
then that phase a little bit
hey
playstation middle tier playstation i'll
be extending to collection tier so to
speak
and then you both say what you think big
clout here's the thing about the
collection in utah where you got the god
of wars i've ever correctly they pretty
much and i've been asked for that for a
while too like them just to add upon
that add more value just to get into it
but
um
i think it was already confirmed a long
time it was they weren't ever going to
no add on to that list so what i see
happening in perpetuity the same games
that's just going to be 20 games those
are like the trial or just the first we
don't get a sub in nobody tags it nobody
talking
no they don't they don't take them out
and i thought they were going to do that
where it'd be like it will refresh let's
say everything a month yeah they don't
do that they don't do that so what i see
what you just said that will be there
for you but that's going to be there for
an additional you know what their
statement today is
what's up if you want more than these
games we got a subscription service
that that's disappointing because
the reason why they do it again the
reason why is that sony is like
i don't even know how we we've got to
that point where people are championing
paying
for 70. seven dollars in general
listen oh people in the chat are saying
persona's leaving yeah
no but it's just again i i thought that
would be a great opportunity for them to
take advantage of something like that
and look this is just a revamp you guys
said it best katie said like
there's one positive service with places
plus and a failing service replay
station now let's merge it let's see if
we can get you know something off top of
it and and that's where i'm at you know
what's up the now had potential to be
fire if it was done right when they
first talked about streaming it but the
thing is if we didn't
if we didn't already have that bad like
experience for it out the gate right
this was just another like them just now
buying guy guy maybe we'd be excited
right the thing is
streaming games and streaming movies
just are two completely different you
know no absolutely things say it's tough
and you can't really put that behind
like you just can't do it there's too
many inputs involved in these games and
all that yeah and my thing is i really
want the commitment to the download
option and i really want a commitment to
the catalog and i want a list can i have
a list of what i'm getting no you know
i'm saying that that's what i was a
major no basis and you don't need to
know
and my final point is look i will say in
fairness i will say
you know when gay pass did launch let's
be real
it wasn't what it is now this is the
camera
no no no but we got to be fair like
it was it evolved into right
it was people exactly it was 360 games
it was it wasn't day and date off the
rip let's be honest right so what i'm
hoping is that it grows it grows to that
also what i would like because we would
talk about live service i would like
if a couple of those i mean they did it
with destruction all-star all-stars
right to be honest
those are going to be free-to-play right
i would like at least if there's an
investment in a commitment to the live
service model can we get any one of
those live service games in that premium
make this premium
i'm not paying for no trial and no demo
i'm not doing it that's what you you're
going to do
[Laughter]
let's see what they're going to do
they're going to dig up let me take that
back let me let me tell you they're
going to get me
yeah what
it's an odd message when sony's the one
out here talking about their games are
so good they have to be seventy dollars
but then also trying to put games out
for free to play yeah like clash
like well i thought your games are so
good every 70 well not this game
it's a very interesting uh we just got
to wait and see how this thing going
goes eric get some chests we got to set
up whole because we got a spicy one that
i need him for even though time may be
limited you know really quickly yes and
i'm usually not messy so i'll be messy
here
i think sony should do day and date more
on pc sooner than later because then at
least horizon forbidden west would have
lasted longer than six days well you
know what
this is seed and this is the thing that
i was talking about
with the numbers thing
right um the failures
they're starting to mount up now
on the horizon and you have the next one
in gran turismo can we see the
the numbers
i never thought i'd see playstation
dudes all of a sudden say
from software
it's overrated that blew me away i'm
like from software gave us one of the
best playstation exclusives of all time
and that was bloodhorn yes right
so we don't want to give them their
flowers it also gave you a a release
date title like so oh no they didn't do
that no that was the blue point
that was their game that game wouldn't
originated without from
but but it kills me though because it's
like okay so it doesn't have the
playstation studios logo on this all of
a sudden we're just immediately going to
say they're overrated oh horizon's
better it's got more legs i'm like uh if
you played alden ring you would know
it's fair boy stuff we never get it and
i'm not going to disrespect all right
but to king's credit
it's just i mean listen we're going
we're going to keep the same energy
right i mean i'm not going to let them
dip i'm not going to let them dodge i'm
not going to let them slide out the way
where's the
i want the numbers
i want the numbers i want the numbers
because you're having people pay 70
dollars
and obviously these games aren't up to
snuff oh my god
stuff there listen listen because it
came out broken oh it came free r kelly
just want to say one thing to you sir
if you don't have the numbers please
don't talk
so that way kick so that's what we do we
all we only talk about them
okay i will read you the beginning of
this super chat that he said he said
here's some numbers king that's all i'm
gonna read you from that one
no you might read it because he's coming
from microsoft crown jewel halo infinite
lost 95 percent of the players so much
for that 10-year plan sony diabetes 18
of the players of horizon finished the
game
so so so i just want to i just want to
say here
i don't know anyway look it's getting
spicy so add it let's get some chests
about what it goes left because i i need
to back to my talk style let's get these
in the chest
shipping out broken games just just to
be uh transparent here uh my youtube
chat refreshed the only thing i can see
is super chats i can't see yeah so we
miss member chats we apologize in
advance this is what happens when we
don't have soft we're messy we have a
two dollar superstition from jd gamer
i'm not paying for demos whose idea was
that it was king i have we have a five
dollar super chat from cedric h
professor king
we have a five super chat from matt
titchbar whatever king's reading glass
is coming out like an accountant of xbox
we have a five dollar subject from ko3
black truth jim is a hustler baby he
sells water to a whale
we have a five dollar strip from smitty
smith sony's premium tier is treating
their fans like abby ready to receive yo
wow okay okay okay okay
absolutely
from absolute swords so now they expect
us to pay for blue balls moving on
we got a five ten dollar signature from
loose said what
uh jim on his mad dre can you actually
he could matt drake can uh he can talk
uh a cat off a fish wagon or sell an
eskimo ice at a high price and get him
twice he ate that nice that's a nice we
got a five dollar shipping donataku
going to have it eventually add cultural
into a tier called playstation plus
ultra
no they're not they have a 20 dollar
face to
face 23 face phase 23 why don't you ask
your lord and save yourself spencer to
give the option for paying game pass
ultimate for a year and keep getting
monthly cost consumption
let me let me respond to him real quick
talk about it
i'm hoping if anything positive happens
from this restructure that's what's
going on competition i like how yes oh
so competition is none they remain on
the top like the sun open whoever comes
in the chamber of torture they told you
oh you should have brought your
neighborhood to support you don't come
for me unless i send for you
you're going with this week's service
they wasn't even ready for today how do
you gonna tell them i'll see you in june
[Laughter]
we gonna knuckle up see you in june
man if you don't get away from me i do
feel your i don't like the fact this is
a blog post and it's not ready i've got
to say that in my balls like it was not
ready
a blog post you just put it out there yo
check it out
and continue okay
i got you block black hobbit two dollars
of a chat just get the playstation now
for 60 before june okay
you caught up or you're gonna take one
then we got
is it me or did dl hu
hoogly jason schreier and will smith
come together to make this game pass
killer you're better off burning your
money literally
you got a two dollar subject from donald
otaku mark cerny can't run ps3 on that
unstable box
we got a ten dollar super chat from
smelly wrestling geek
how long until microsoft adds a year
subscription office for game pass glad
they're finally adding a family plan how
much per month do you think that will be
i don't know right now
i would say uh
probably around 30 dollars
probably probably for the year be 216.
cute clang new zealand eight uh 999
super chat as someone who loves getting
past i want players plus extra to be
successful enough for sony to see the
value in date and date and then we're
going to take over attico you got it
yeah yeah go ahead i got you uh creep
creeper evox 2000 chat it's not a
competitor it's a defeated statement
a year after xbox gameplay station now
started allowing downloads of ps4 games
that's true don't let anyone tell you
they're not trying to compete with game
pass they just can't
spartan ghost 17 two pounds super chat
get rid of pcp in them sony oh my god
mack titchbon
uh to ten pounds super chat sony not
knowing what gamers want is the same as
them now knowing what cinemagoers want
and then wondering why they flop no
please give me more origin films for
c-list spider-man villains okay
jd gabriel files up a chat sony thinks
they're disney and that microsoft is
netflix so expect sony to offer day and
date at a cost at some point say thirty
dollars in players plus per minute
subscription makai 28. uh us he got five
dollars in the chat we've been playing
spartacus two years ago
all right here come freon kelly back off
a long hiatus 20 mile super chat it's
he's missing in action he's a mission in
action after he bet they need to king
last time um it's over i predicted this
last year king game pass is finished
have a good sunday y'all
jd gamer 20 chat responds to r kelly
stop the cap i'm not paying for demos
and backpack i'll get their service but
it's an actual good deal so until then
stop the fight you get a good deal with
game passer freer kelly follow some chat
back at jd gamer you rent it on xbox i'm
owning on playstation you ain't owning
anything slow down
[Laughter]
there's a reason sony bought destiny 2.
look at halo lost 95 percent of the
blacks xbox is done jim thanos ryan
finishing microsoft wait a second uh i
don't know jd i think he's kind of
stopping you right now wait wait wait
wait they didn't coming back he got too
much
they brought destiny too
it's for the streets for everybody what
the hell are you talking about you think
they stopped selling their own xbox one
they told them in the contract we for
the streets
jp gamer claps back found some chat they
have an award with the super chat free r
kelly i own all console as i always have
stop watching my pockets and look at
playstation picking yours jd gamer again
find out some chats
r kelly haven't you ever been taught to
read the fine print i'm renting and
buying as i play
some playing sony playing games i'd like
wondering why you have none okay
shiny 10 hours of chat whether we like
it or not playstation is already a
monopoly in the console space
for most devs double a or triple a space
they are beholden to the tyranny of sony
they have substantial market share and
leverage it okay lady scion 10 super
chat hold up fan saying sorry i get to
correct you once thank you because you
know it's anime and i'm i'm incorrect
ten dollars
hold up why are we saying let's wait and
see for quality to come to game pass as
last year already show quality is in
game pass tunic which i will shout from
the rooftops is a quality game shot the
ladies well i didn't say that i said
consistent quality okay that's what i
said
jdk oh wow jd gamer is still on our
kelly's next phones which i
kelly oh and thanos is dead snapped away
now if you're talking about jim dance
rules ryan he's finding new steps almost
weekly at this point freya kelly with
the recent clap back this last one i got
um i think he could take off after this
final super chat here's some numbers
king oh this is the one week he said it
again microsoft crown jewel okay
live free r kelly jd gamer done throwing
spirit bomb straight in your face it was
it was an intense console war going on
and then gamer definitely won we will be
really
absolutely he dropped he dropped a tiny
tina code in the chat i appreciate it
thank you what's up we got a five dollar
super drive from jd gamer king say i
want the numbers oh and why does gt 7
look like a ps3 game when it's not in
the replay ridiculous and why no 120
boost on the ps5 digital foundry that
all right so we we all good folks no no
there's still more
that i guess it's a good problem uh then
we have a two dollar shoe trap from uh
ham solo yeah give them that
that duralimite
dolomites
oh that dole of my job talking okay i
know what he's doing i don't
and i think we have another huddle of me
yeah i got him um dorian gray follow
some chat three guys got ps3 games to
run on an emulator or pc and a
multi-billion company and mark cerny
can't get it done
they can get it done they just don't
want to okay michael patton two dollar
super chat xbox virtuous cycle is an 87
meter critic okay you know i i i want to
be extra messy uh put a one in the chat
if you feel like jd gabriel won that
article oh my god
it was intense
it was very console warrior it was
intense but look we got to move on hogue
has been extremely patient i really
really want his time for this topic
there's a lot going on right now u.s
senators versus microsoft ftc reviewing
the deal for potential monopolistic
power to harm or lessen the competition
hog law of hulk law business law firm
sweet subscribe to his channel y'all the
whole globe channels excellent work
virtual legality reasonable minds can
differ but also gives grip perspective
here so whole for those who have not
watched this amazing video which you
should put hoglar's uh uh information in
chat y'all there's a lot of y'all here
please subscribe to the channel if you
haven't already excellent work so hope
what's going on here you know we're
seeing things
in senators getting involved with gay
what's happening hulk
so i the really short story here as best
i can tell is that they have a bill
they'd like to promote and that's a
mechanism that they use to try to do it
the longer answer is that it's a
political season it's an election year
for at least some of the folks um and
this is something that has captured the
imagination of a lot of people as you
can tell from the somewhat in congress
tweets that come
behind senator warren's statements or
senator sanders of sony people saying
thank you for trying to stop the evil
monolith of xbox and things like that
people are invested in their gaming
consoles i know this is a surprise to
all of us who talk about these things
regularly
but i think what you've got is a
combination of things you've got a
technology bent that the ftc and the doj
has taken you've got a bid
administration executive order that says
we're worried about technology companies
microsoft is a technology company buying
activision really isn't what they're
generally talking about you know they
make call of duty it's not like
chipsets or something that can go into
the energy sector or weapons or
something along those lines
but it is a technology company and
fundamentally even though you might have
seen it reported on as they want to stop
this deal for monopolistic reasons or
whatever their letter comes down to
overall the fact that activision
blizzard is a bad actor
and they feel that this transaction will
hurt
workers leverage over the microsoft
entity because they have some momentum
going right now fundamentally this is a
story about four senators who are
backing up unionization efforts
specifically at raven where they're
happening but also across activision
blizzard and believe that the
transaction will hurt the leverage and
hurt the possibilities of that happening
i'm sorry i'll continue
no i it's absolutely fine i can answer
any questions you have as we go along
the the anti-trust laws
are not really supposed to be read to
talk about specific secondary
stakeholders whether that's workers
whether that's vendors whether that's
other competitors the laws themselves
are in favor of competition on the whole
right because that leads to better and
cheaper products for consumers so for at
least the last 50 years they have been
read by the supreme court and obviously
the courts to filter out from down there
to be based on are consumers hurt by
this kind of thing right if microsoft
buys activision is some product being
held back is some price going up at the
end user level because anything above
that taking into account our workers
harmed our vendors harmed or other
things that go into the inputs of the
production manufacturer home that has no
end
there's no logical end point discus
discussing that because somebody is a
winner and somebody's a loser in any
kind of transaction right so the anatrus
laws have traditionally focused on end
users consumers are we going to be hurt
and when i've talked in the past i think
even maybe here yeah talk to the past
about hey this is an 80 20 chance of
this deal going through the basic
concept was if the ftc or the doj wanted
to move against this deal they would say
okay
well if you take away all this content
are you monopolizing most likely the
nascent market for game subscription
services right right are you trying to
crush playstation or whoever else might
want to bring one in the crib and that
makes it so that you can jack the price
up higher right because if they don't
have any way to go and get zenimax games
or any way to go and get activision
games you have a lot more control
potentially over the secondary market
that feeds your position in the
subscription service market and i think
that's a bit attenuated i think it's 80
chance that they don't go that direction
but the ftc like all executive agencies
like people in washington in general are
political bodies and they could be
seeing all of the signals from the buy
administration from other people and say
well if we were going to go after this
deal this is what it would look like
gotcha similarly these senators come out
with this letter and say activision
blizzard is terrible look at what
california accused them of look at what
the eoc accused them of look at the
investigation the sec is doing and look
at their nascent uh workers rights
efforts the cwa and the nlrb hearing and
this is going to kill that but also
really the thing that gives it away in
the last paragraph
and by the way our bill that's currently
happening in front of the senate would
help solve all of this and it's like
okay so as a lawyer i look at it and i
say i understand where you're coming
from and i understand being concerned
about workers rights
it's not the fact that every specific
nail
is subject to the hammer that you have
right so when we talk about the ftc when
we talk about the antitrust system it
really isn't designed for this kind of
thing if they got their way and the law
changed if they passed their law it
would be they have things like banning 5
billion or more transactions which i
think are problematic on their face but
we're not here to talk about the
politics of their bill but if they pass
this law it also has a section that says
you'll take into account worker's
leverage positions uh and not just
consumer welfare or competition on the
whole that is a different paradigm than
what we have right now so i look at that
letter and i complain a little bit and i
say well
you're asking the ftc to enforce
something that the supreme court and any
court below it would likely knock down
because you believe the law should be
changed to something else and or you're
doing it as a fundraising politicians
politics is they have all sorts of good
reasons to do that for the reasons that
have been established in politics i
don't tend to love politicians but
that's neither here nor there on either
side of the aisle right in this
particular case it's important for
people to understand that this is as
much a kind of public relations
political thing as it is anything else i
did however in my video say i'm probably
going to reduce it from 80 20 to 75 25
not because they bring up a good point
under the laws right now but primarily
because sometimes you do get kind of a
a crowd mentality okay if those four
senators go out there and then a few
more want to join in right you make
enough of a din and that's going to
actually impact the ftc's evaluation
because they are a political body
themselves let me
ask that's the that's the short version
that's the show yeah i got four i got
more questions for for whole um real
quick uh because i i gotta follow up
with a few you know yeah so so here's
the thing right now
the goal
is the preliminary injunction right that
it is is is that i guess my my question
is
to get this kind of
stoppage of this of this deal right you
know my question is what is the
alternative
to
microsoft not owning them if they're if
they're against this in theory right
even though you brought up some eloquent
points about you know this this
potentially could be political posturing
for
a bill or law that does not exist that
would
stop something like this but what's
currently in place may not so but my
question is okay
is explicitly mentioned
okay well if microsoft we don't want
this to happen right so what is the
alternative
with microsoft does it have is is that
explicitly stated as something with a
goal since their concern is for the
workers and fair treatment at activision
yeah let's back up a step okay so when
the ftc is looking at this um under the
clayton act through the auspices of the
heart scott rodino act they are looking
to see if the deal itself reduces
competition right and that is generally
determined by whether consumers are hurt
that's kind of separate what powers do
they have to actually do anything about
it they have primarily one they have one
chainsaw super weapon that they can use
on these things and that's to go sue in
federal court to stop the deal from
happening right um and so that's what
they have but that's a big old weapon
that they can point at people and so the
secondary thing that happens in a
significantly higher number of cases
than that actually go into federal court
is they can say microsoft we have this
weapon we won't pull the trigger if you
can agree to certain things with us and
that's separate that can be anything in
the universe
i've talked about it in different spaces
they say yeah you can mandate the call
of duty appears for five years you can
do anything you want of course microsoft
has to agree because they know that you
may or may not have a good gun to use
against them right when we're talking
about this the ftc can say well we know
that this is anti-competitive for reason
x y and z microsoft is either [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and they can say go prove it in federal
court we got the money we got the
lawyers let's go do this thing
and but with any kind of credible claim
the ftc can walk up and say all right we
got this letter from the senators we
think we can make a case that a court
won't kick out immediately if we talk
about game pass or cloud services or
something like that here's what we want
we want this kind of thing that you
pledge for exclusivity whatever it might
be part of that could be you agree that
if we get x number of signature cards in
you will just voluntarily acknowledge a
union like that's one of the things
we're worried about now that's separate
from what they should actually be
looking at but microsoft could agree to
that separately right at that point
you're just discussing terms it's just
you've settled on negotiating you're
just establishing the price
so microsoft could have seen to that
they don't want to be bound by that
right microsoft is
pretty notoriously non-union and you
could take that one of two ways they
bust or they provide the employees what
they want depends on what side you look
at these kind of things
but microsoft generally avoids that for
their their workforce and so they
wouldn't want a consent decree that's
the settlement agreement you'd have with
the ftc to do these things in fact you
might have seen the phrase consent
decree referenced by phil and sachin and
yes where they say we don't think a
consent decree should be required for
these various things this is when
they're pitching that call of duty is
going to be available on playstation
gotcha so we don't want to be forced
because you never want to be forced if
you think something voluntarily that
gets you to not sign something that
mandates it that's where you want to
live microsoft but ftc basically only
has a nuclear weapon as an option right
they can threaten the full shebang we're
just going to stop the whole thing right
everything before that is essentially a
settlement agreement that says don't
kill it so
that's that's the tools they have in
their tool belt is kind of more nuanced
than that good do you think that there
might be some people speaking against it
but i think it would be fair to say that
you know loki obviously
these giant companies they they they got
i wouldn't say they got centers in their
pocket but they got people that highly
recommend certain certain companies for
certain things you think it's safe to
assume that microsoft might have so some
people in
congress that that that are all for it
like
well congress
isn't looking at this that's one of the
things that's a little bit odd for
senators to kind of speak out at this
stage they've done it in the past um
certainly but
congress ostensibly shouldn't be
involved at this point they they ra they
wrote the antitrust laws now it's in the
executive branch
i would never ever accuse any
corporation of bribing officials
of any kind but certainly microsoft has
a lobbying arm and can advocate for
certain changes in the law
those wouldn't be necessary for what
we're looking at here in terms of what
the senators argued for which is paying
attention to workers leverage i think
the last line in their letter is like if
you find that the worker's leverage
would be harmed by this deal you should
oppose it right and i look at it and go
no that's not that's that's not how the
law works right because the law works
just to kind of frame it as i do in my
video is if you show a merger to the ftc
that can
double the output because of the
technology synergies or whatever you can
double the output of the product reduce
the price in half and reduce the work
the workforce that it takes to build it
in half
that's something that the laws say is
good
right that less labor making more stuff
cheaper
is is better for consumers and allows
that corporation to be more competitive
but obviously the workforce is harmed
and so you have to decide exactly what
you're looking at that's they're
advocating for something different from
what the law has historically been read
to me right which is fine that's
politics that's their purview they're in
congress right
this new law popping that don't exist
yet continue right so do i think that
microsoft can talk to the ftc can dock
back channels sure
i'm not sure that they would have to on
this spot and to be honest with you
microsoft knows better right this minute
exactly how the ftc is thinking about
these things because they would already
started the process of the investigation
um so you'll get a feel for it
potentially if microsoft does a little
bit more um juggling right like they did
with the blog with the blog post which
was like in favor of epic and like the
coalition for fairness which is like an
ancillary point you're just trying to
collect brownie points um uh in in
washington if you see more of that you
probably will but if you see it at a
high degree you you get a feel for that
they think they need to do a little
dancing right there so that would be
more of an indicator that okay we need
to get this across the finish line
microsoft is on the hook for between two
and three billion dollars if the
regulators strike this down
um so they that's why activision
negotiated for that right it's microsoft
that's mostly going to be in charge of
getting this across the finish line okay
if you fail we don't want you walking
away for free because activation is
essentially a study of stasis right now
right all hell breaks loose if this deal
falls through so microsoft do your best
and if you don't you owe us three
billion dollars the the joke i use is
the feds are watching so we have to do
everything
but uh wha i want to i want to say this
on
my last quest before i open up anybody i
have some questions for you on this is
that in fairness right even though
to me based on your video based on what
you're saying now you know i have to
admit it does sound a bit political
posturing slash grandstanding i'm gonna
be honest you know i usually don't do
the politic thing here on i'll people
it's pertaining to gaming so i have to
talk standing is equal no matter your
political claim i don't view it as a
political stance they're being
politicians they're being politicians
and the vibe i get yes there's a law
that does not exist that they would like
to present that would be able to maybe
have jurisdiction over deals like this
and so on and so forth but my question
is like
you know
in in terms of
this you know the monopolistic talk
which i find interesting right
and i look at like activision themselves
the way they were created right you you
look at you look at like respawn like
they were able to break away
and then form you know companies
successfully themselves under the
current structure that exists so it's
just interesting to me this
wanting to infuse and get it get ahead
of this i was very i'll be honest hulk i
was very surprised by this i did not the
substance of the letter yes yes yeah so
i mean that's the thing that you brought
up that i didn't bring up because they
aren't silly i call them silly but
they're trying to tie their argument
into
the the actual existing antitrust act so
they try to describe this problem with
workers as microsoft becoming what we
call a monopsony
buyer of labor services which is just
the opposite of a monopoly if you think
monopolies is sellers there's only one
seller in the market monopoly means
they're only one buyer in the market
yeah and i say this in my video i don't
usually say things that are this
specific i'm a lawyer i say hey this is
this possibility this is this
possibility this is what i think it but
i say that is insane for the video game
market because activision blizzard big
company 10 000 workers out of hundreds
of thousands across the globe and more
importantly
making video games is not making cars it
doesn't need a huge factory and all this
real estate the history of the gaming
industry is the history of activision as
you rightly point out it's a history of
going and saying screw these guys we're
going to go build our own
and so that makes it so that there isn't
that same kind of labor analysis in this
specific industry because laptops and
friends are going to get you where you
need to be in making video games might
not be as easy as somebody with all the
bells and whistles in the office and
those kinds of things but it's it's a
history that we see there is a huge
amount of fluidity in
people making video games moving across
these employers and the numbers don't
even work for that right microsoft
getting 10 000 more video game
developers doesn't change microsoft
doesn't suddenly become the only place
to sell video game development services
right not even close so they try to tie
it that way to make sure that they've
got a hook that's it's at least talking
about antitrust a little bit but that
one to me is flatly obvious as
inapplicable to what we're talking about
fair enough ran out through a big cloud
anybody's got all the lords there you
got a question i don't know how to
deliver it i wonder if i got any
questions for hope
yeah i was gonna say um do you uh
are you surprised or uh by all the
attention that the deal is getting since
the very beginning like did you expect
this sort of uh treatment
yeah at that number and with that party
line so what i mean by that is 70
billion is a lot in any industry we're
used to seeing it in some of them but
you cross
you're getting a double-digit billions
really you're going to get some kind of
attention unless you're smart enough to
buy zynga the day before microsoft
then it just goes by the way something
is just sneaking around
microsoft as a party line was also an
important part of this puzzle because
they're looking at big tech and
microsoft mostly avoids some of this
because they're really focused on
internet and social media and google and
apple and amazon and those kinds of
things but microsoft is
obviously a tech giant and so it's easy
to kind of roll them back in and
everybody i think has at least an
institutional memory of the fact that
microsoft has been in antitrust trouble
before that microsoft is regularly
brought before congress and has had
these conversations and got sued for
bundling so microsoft
is
always going to get this kind of look
when they make these kinds of moves
because they have that history with the
us government already
even when i still think it's attenuated
it's buying a video game publisher it
puts them into a certain position i
think you have to actually stretch to
make that argument about game pass and
cloud that's why i give it an 80 or 75
chance of going through but you can also
see that the market isn't sure right i
talk about this a lot which is it's a 95
asset if it's going to happen and it's
selling for like 78
yeah
which is
using the information from potential
investors to say
uh we're not positive that this is going
to go through and they have it at about
that same clip 80 75 percent something
along those lines so you look at that
and i think
it was always obvious from the start you
don't see that number popping anywhere
near 95 uh when it is announced that
this was going to be a big deal you just
had to buy an administration executive
order that says we're going to take a
closer look at tech
and a closer look at antitrust then you
have the ftc and the doj have a combined
press conference
i think that same week it says we're
going to re-examine our merger
guidelines we're going to enforce it
more harshly we're going to enforce it
more harshly specifically against tech
companies and you say okay
well i don't think this is the greatest
fit for them they would prefer this was
amazon or uh facebook trying to buy
another
competitor that's the silver bullet but
this one is still hey this is sexy this
is a sexy industry that people are
really interested in it's bigger than
movies it's a big name party and it's a
heck of a lot of money so yes i always
thought this was going to get this kind
of look no doubt big cloud your question
for hope
uh yeah so i've seen this deal uh
happened you know like there's been like
that 50 50 uh split hulk like there are
people who are really for it and those
who are against people tweeting that
senators right now it's real yeah i mean
yeah so the reason i was going to have
that kid
the question i was gonna ask you like um
how do you feel about the uh
like the whole situation like the 50 50
split i said it flat out like on boom
show that you know there is a big
positive to microsoft buying them
because of unionization they can get rid
of everybody who's pretty much brought
this company down
and put better management in this right
to lead to better games better content
for everybody but there are a lot of
people who really believe that they
shouldn't do this and we're good what we
got but if you look at the games in the
state of the call of duty franchise
it has not been good right there hasn't
been no real quality game and the games
that they've published have been few and
far between have actually been had like
a good i guess crazy reception like for
example securo had a really good
reception so i'm just curious what your
thoughts on the uh
the merger i guess yeah i mean this era
of consolidation is tricky right because
i think reasonable people can look at it
and say well if we put all our eggs in
one or two or even three baskets we
start to really lose potential variety
we have a higher risk for the whole
industry and it's it's not like we're
hundreds of years from the 80s crash so
you've seen these kinds of things happen
when they get a little bit too
consolidated uh on the other hand
i have long been in favor personally
since microsoft jumped in with the xbox
of them actually using their resources
to participate as they could in this
industry right and i am to give my tilt
so that people understand i'm a mergers
and acquisitions
corporate tilted guy
in favor in general of transactions and
better living through synergies and all
that good stuff so my tilt is towards
all right you're going to put 80 billion
dollars at this industry that you have
to go get return on investment from that
shows a couple of things one that you
believe that this industry is going to
grow and that this is a worthwhile place
to spend valuable cash money because
microsoft invest in anything correct
microsoft can invest in a moon base
microsoft has decided to invest in
activision and xenomax and overall i
think having a competitor in the market
that is willing to invest those
resources that is evidence that they're
here for the long haul is a good thing
that competition is a good thing that
the last generation between xbox
playstation made me sad because tv tv tv
yeah yeah yeah
i like that i do however also sympathize
with those folks and say
well okay microsoft could just buy
everybody um and and sony as you
probably heard me just say with respect
to the playstation plus stuff i think is
slow to react and they've never sony
gaming dealt with this kind of situation
before microsoft was essentially a
sleeping giant and has just decided
to go nuts and that's why sony's doing
those quick side deals now you know we
just said it with the haven studios we
set it with uh fire sprite
making the purchases buying early right
they're buying higher risk companies
earlier because they can because if they
were to just get into a fight and say oh
this is a proven company right
microsoft's going to win in most bids
right so you don't want to have that
fight sony has great development i love
my playstation i like sony
would you say that they're looking for
like that next kojima productions type
of studio like that big
impact impact it's an open question
right because i think if kojima was
doing his thing if we just push the
konami uh departure a few years forward
i think they buy his studio before death
stranding comes out right right now they
look at what that is and they just buy
it they're relocating so you know that's
a big thing going around well they have
that close relationship the one thing i
would say is difficult there is much
like ted price was at insomniac i have a
sneak in suspicion hideo is a little bit
reluctant to give up autonomy um after
after his experiences and having worked
with founders my whole career it's the
kind of history where you say um i'm a
little bit more standoffish so that
could mean a couple of things the check
is bigger that can solve some problems
yes check big bang
or it's just that we're going to work
very closely together right insomniac i
think at least
was like the best budget price that
students
sold itself for pennies but but they
were just done but for the longest time
i don't think anyone would have been uh
remiss in claiming that they were a sony
studio already i mean outside of the
occasional sunset overdrive kind of
thing right it's hard to imagine them as
not being sony
like quantico dream i'm surprised sony
never invested in quantity dream i don't
think that i think that was more like a
prestige play right like that's the
channel that has that one emmy nominated
kind of game company and i don't think
that i don't think quantic dream games
ever move the needle on sales too much
i'd have to look at it they made an
impact with heavy rain i know because
that was the one that kind of like
pushed them for it but then the one that
really i guess put them on the map map
was detroit
yeah i'd have to look at the numbers for
detroit but i i suspect that
also when they were evaluating sales is
when exactly quantic dreams had the yeah
the scandals the scandal
so shout out to all peter 420 he didn't
want to get this in and this has been a
question you know with this deal going
potentially going through you know or
not going through like
what what what's this it's there do you
think that this could put them on hold
for other big acquisitions say for
example like a ubisoft or anything or
like for example right now i've had this
discussion with manny on the final duke
like i'm of the mindset that maybe
everything kind of stops right now
and all hands on deck with the ftc to
get this thing through the finish line
or do you see a scenario where they
still could attend potentially acquire
another publisher or studio
during this time period of the
activision deal try to be worked out i
think they could buy a little guy you
know they just decided that they were
going to roll up and buy the mercury
street schemes of the world that kind of
thing okay i think it's not all hands on
deck it's not like they're lacking in
resources to consummate a second deal
right essentially a we don't want to
buzz the tower bank while the ftc is
analyzing us yes so i i think that it's
right any really big one ubisoft ea and
any really large one would not go
through right now because what's
important is getting that across the
finish line correct um so i i don't see
a world in which microsoft makes it like
a huge splash but maybe a significant
splash to some people and there are
games companies out there that are
making things independently that are you
know important to people that microsoft
could probably buy
if you're talking about you know a
couple hundred million uh rather than
rather than something with a b
in the number
fandom last question for me is um
in fairness you know obviously we've
talked about what we think the the
motivation here politically but um my
question is what about those who say
look you know there were a lot of bad
actors at activision right there were a
lot of things that are going on um as
random laughs like this as jazz
adequately calls he doesn't call him bob
he calls him robert
[Laughter]
robert cote right your co-host jess from
the xbox two cents he because of robert
kotek and um you know a lot of people
are upset that hey he's going to get a
potentially golden parachute he's going
to be able to ride off into the sunset
live on an island somewhere you know
and there won't be any repercussion is
there any fairness to say that there's
and that could be another reasoning to
make sure that the proper
justice goes to those who
were part or may have been included with
the well i'm gonna get a little real
politic maybe a little nihilist on you
which i don't know it's what i'm known
for yes uh but uh
he never was
um so
he he never was separately accused right
correct that is back division on the
whole that is correct uh the expose from
the wall street journal came out to the
extent they can prove those direct
actions by him he would still be on the
hook regardless
but he owns a significant percentage not
that significant in terms of controlling
it but in terms of when you've got 70
billion on the line enough to make you a
pretty happy person when you get those
sales those shares sold right that was
always going to happen if activision was
ever going to eject him entirely they
were going to buy the shares uh if
activision was ever going to eject him
and have some kind of control over what
he says after he leaves they were always
going to have some kind of severance
package
regardless what happens he was getting
that goal
you don't own that much stalk and then
not get a golden parachute
that's the nature of the beast
unfortunately i don't blame anybody that
critiques it on the whole but to
critique it separately as as a problem
with this particular transaction is a
little bit too far for me because
there's no world
in which that doesn't happen even if
activation blizzard tries to save itself
by ejecting all the management that's a
buyout that's a release that's a
severance package right he might not get
as much but he's still getting a golden
bag
he might not get as much he he might
though i mean i you look at what's
described in the various aspects of the
proxy statement in the merger it's he's
getting brought back up to where he
would have been
um and so i don't blame anybody
including the senators for having a
paragraph because everybody hates bobby
kozick and it's kind of the easiest kind
of slam dunk you can do
by saying look at this evil guy and this
evil guy is going to get money out of
this deal but the problem i do have with
it is you say you stopped the deal
and one there's plenty of employees from
active blizzard i see online saying
they're looking forward to working under
new management i did see it effectively
and and i have a problem with third
parties whether that's cwa whether
that's the senator's coming in and
saying effectively these people should
suffer because they have a position of
leverage and we want them to use that
leverage to create a precedent that to
me feels like we don't care about their
individualized suffering um and it's
actually kind of reminiscent of what
california did by trying to block the
eoc settlement effectively saying these
women that were affected that deserve
redress
shouldn't be allowed to select their own
settlement they should have to go with
the california litigation and as i said
in my videos it's like
they're not they're
their problems what they experienced at
activision is not owned by the state of
california so similarly if these people
are suffering under current management
and there's a chance that microsoft can
come in and cleanse some of that and i'm
not saying it's a guarantee people come
to my comments and say we don't know
microsoft will be any better it's like
well we know what activision blizzard is
we know the problems that they've had um
and yeah microsoft has had problems
historically they had they had a sexual
harassment
shareholders they just had their
shareholders very recently forced them
to start reporting on it against the
wishes of the board of directors correct
big companies have issues that need to
get solved but i think that changing
management is a potentially good option
for what we can start to see is what
looks like rot from the outside and i'm
not saying that because i'm standing in
the room i've said that in all my videos
i don't know the specifics of this and i
think california's lawsuit actually has
significant problems especially on the
pay disparity side right but we can tell
from their messaging we can tell from
how they responded how they blew up
their own stock price by being morons
you can tell from the jen o'neill
situation that they don't know what
they're doing to handle this stuff and i
say let's let's let another rider try
this horse
and so that's the problem i have with it
reasonable minds can differ on that
reasonable alliance can look at that and
say they're trying to help the people
this is how they're going to get the
first big union in aaa in united states
video gaming i get all that
personally i have a problem with that
because if those people are suffering
ending that suffering should be priority
work i think my standpoint on it is like
look
is things going to be change with
microsoft that's up in the air but
clearly things haven't changed in the
past 10 years under activation
alternative no fair enough fair enough
this is great
and uh all right guys two quick all
right whole jd gamer hogue is there a
way to put an acquisition on ice until
this current purchase goes through the
ftc so you can complete it later
is there a way to put it on ice i mean
you could always you could always halt
the offer you've got problems paying
people in various ways and who's
responsible for that chances are that
won't happen chances are they're they're
committed to this you don't put each
side owing the other billion billions of
dollars
right so with that i got i got a quick
question for hog you mentioned that if
this falls through in any way microsoft
owes activision three bills right the
regulator's block regulators block it
and if activision shareholders don't
approve it then they owe microsoft like
2 billion or something right i'd have to
read through the specifics i believe
that's right so these are negotiated
positions so there's two penalties one
from microsoft activation one from
activation to microsoft microsoft's
penalty is owed if the regulators stop
it like theirs is pretty simple
activisions leads to another list of 13
reasons why
they would owe the money back i believe
if the shareholders voted down that
would happen that they would owe that
money i cannot guarantee it because i'm
not looking at the 80 page doc right the
center so if
if um
let's hypothetically let's imagine a
scenario where
government body blocks it whether it's
the us or whether it's the eu right
so it falls through right
do you would in your opinion would there
be any fallout from it
would microsoft then be
less interested in acquiring publishers
in the future because the activision
deal one didn't go through would
somebody have to fall on their sword at
xbox or microsoft because three billion
dollars to give away for nothing is a
lot of money
you know so like would you would there
be any fallout in your opinion if that
you know did happen i would say it would
depend on the reason why it fell through
um you know there are legitimate reasons
why they that maybe microsoft could have
analyzed properly and they didn't get a
good feel for what the politics of the
situation were or whatever that maybe
you had rules or two heads role at that
company if it's something on a left
field if it's something that you're not
expecting and the eu's just acting crazy
or the ftc is acting crazy that has to
be evaluated separately there's no
precedent for what they wound up doing
um you have to you have to evaluate
those things generally
yes i think there would be there would
be big post-mortem conversations about
how this happened uh and what we did
wrong but you had phil spencer on that
phone call you had satya nadella on that
phone call um those are very very
successful people that have made
microsoft a substantial amount of money
and so
it it's difficult to see exactly which
heads would be taken uh except except
for you know like
giving sanctions to mississippi state
when kentucky does something wrong would
it be that kind of thing so i do believe
that
microsoft
knew that there were some risks that's
why they announced it for the summer of
next year at the outside date um and
everybody's kind of incorporated that in
i will also say however to those folks
that come into my comments or social
media elsewhere and say well microsoft
has great lawyers they wouldn't be doing
this if they didn't know it was okay
that's not how any of this works
everybody has great lawyers nvidia had
great uh lawyers when they got their arm
deal struck down
folks are taking reasonable positions
based on calculated risks it does not
mean that they are guaranteed when they
decide to engage in those risks good
point attic and then i gotta kiss
movement that'll be the final question
uh i'm about i'm about to do kids oh
okay cool okay uh kismus says for whole
could square enix sells uh crystal
dynamics to microsoft in the middle of
all this okay keep that in mind but i
want to ask you something i've always
wondered
we've heard a lot of speculation i want
a lawyer to tell
is it is there true that there's all
these precautions that took in place
where an american company can't buy a
japanese company under no circumstances
whatsoever i have to make a video on
this you have to make a video you ask
questions yeah no it is not uh you can
buy into basically any jurisdiction but
there are differing values of hoops that
you have to jump through you might need
a holding company you might need a
specific local on the board of directors
or controlling a management position i
have represented clients that have
purchased like three or four japanese
con companies from an american
headquarters but sometimes with a
japanese subsidiary all sorts of various
things that you might otherwise
pretty much well they're not loopholes
they japan or south america has big
south america has big requirements for
representation that is somebody that's a
citizen on these various things they
want these things organized in a
specific way that they can better
regulate them that they can potentially
help their own economy so it's it's a
matter of complying with them it's more
expensive so yeah
so them owning a company like tango
studios is that like kind of something
that they could do to use that to
leverage that to buy more or is that
just not like how that works well i'd be
speaking out of school because every
time you would do this you'd have
lawyers that go in and look at the
regulations and try to comply you'd
probably have local council that's also
talking to you about what they're
expecting and their mores
but yes
all other things being equal not legal
advice that is the kind of thing that
you could do is you could have tango buy
something in japan
um and so there are ways to buy things
in other jurisdictions every
jurisdiction on earth might be harder
might be more expensive might be
difficult to structure your entities
that way but if you really really want
it you can buy a japanese company and
then his his simple question was oh
right do you think square enix could uh
buy do you think square enix could sell
cursor dynamics to people that's helping
with the initiative in the middle of all
this do you think that could ever happen
yeah so foundationally first of all you
can always spin off a company you can
always sell a portion of your assets and
video game companies especially
publishers are pretty well organized for
that they've got all these different
tunnels that are separate entities
basically um so they 100
legally could say we're going to sell
you the crystal dynamics assets we don't
have to sell you stock you don't have to
buy all the square enix we can just sell
you a portion if that's what makes sense
if the other side of that question is
could they do this while activision
blizzard's going on uh yes i i think
they can tell a good story for how
apparently they alienated all the people
working on perfect dark and need crystal
dynamics
um and they could actually explain why
this purchase was happening again you're
probably talking about hundreds of
millions of dollars not billions i would
guess it's all guesswork but i think
square on its own is only worth 6
billion or so like by itself
um so i think you're talking about
hundreds of millions of dollars
and you could tell that story i think
it's it's a single developer it's
already working on your game the people
that are already working on that game
used to be managers at that company i
believe is the way that story goes um so
i think you could tell that i think you
could tell that story to a regulator
still not i mean you're still taking on
risk but every every move that you make
is is that's where the sequoia balance
on the on the rope right but it's it's
something that i could see them doing uh
honestly i still think that the ftc is
going to mostly let this roll uh so it's
it's really a matter of also a feel for
that atmosphere again microsoft's in
direct contact with the ftc is in direct
contact with its investigators they
already have a slightly better feeling
on something outside
how aggressive they're acting
and i know your time's limited one more
oh my god we're killing hog right now
let's say let's say the activision goes
through which you know you said you
you're pretty sure it will 70 30 was his
last yeah 70 30. so let's say that goes
through do you think microsoft will be a
lot more hesitant it's like we got we
got buy something that we was unsure of
do you think that it might prevent them
from jumping out the ship again and
buying another publisher
uh
with all of their messaging and all of
their signaling i would say no i would
say it requires a longer discussion
if they saw something that they thought
was undervalued that would materially
add to this product offering that they
are making
they would run with it microsoft is
acting very aggressively there's nothing
wrong with that but they're acting with
a if the risk is
even potentially 20 percent as i'm
describing here or more
let's roll with it let's risk three
billion dollars because we think we can
get it through um and if we do get it
through you know the uh people think
well does that make them stop or does it
make them more nervous potentially makes
them the opposite well hell we ate a
seventy billion dollar fish arguing
about this okay
look man this is amazing well where's
your youtube channel yeah but we listen
man we we gotta celebrate the amazing
because i'm gonna need that that whole
that japanese video
i'll try to get it done yes you to get
that done that has been amazing brother
hulk i appreciate you for coming through
in the 11th hour
man i'm so proud of you man i am so
proud to see where you're going and
what's your 60 000 60 000
bro when i see
what makes me smile is when i see other
publications and i see you quoted and
people hit me like wait a minute wasn't
that the guy you had off the way back i
was like yeah that's my guy oh look man
i brought you brother you're killing it
absolute pleasure to always have you in
the realm get your insight once again
for the people who do not know where can
they find
rick hope
yes well thank you and i really
appreciate the kind words uh virtual
legality is us talking about business
and law a lot about video games pop
culture other ways that it pops up and
that's on my youtube channel that's
hoglaw youtube.com
law thank you you can find virtual
gallery there we did a video on the
bungie lawsuit against their alleged
fraudsters which is really 25 pages of
them screaming at youtube i highly
recommend them it is an enjoyable
complaint and i think that video is uh
one of our best uh but we did that we
talked about playstation plus we talked
about this senator's letter we are
always doing that in virtual legality
thankfully the gaming industry is always
providing us content uh so please come
over check us out we're gonna be at 60
000 subscribers very soon i'm very
pumped about that let's get them to 60k
y'all hit that like subscribe
nelson rivera just subscribe to the
channel my man good team awesome and if
you like my hot takes on things like the
halo television show and other things
that really irritate people like nasty
bags
i can confirm he's got hardships he's
got hot takes that's effect final
fantasy
same spelling
no no that also on a big cast of my good
friends aidsley bowden
i got to get that all into the thing i
came right from there i've been
streaming since the 11th
that's why i feel so guilty that you
come like this doing everything i love
you guys what did i tell you in dm time
i told you you did first of all you were
the first invite that anybody ever gave
me which i had what did i have 500
subscribers something like that i was
like this guy's just fantastic you're
always a priority so ask whenever you
want but yeah this conversation is
fantastic we have good talks here even
though i got to ease back on some of the
xboy fan oh
king oh man
oh i love king i love kids
i got so many people in my freaking
comments telling me i'm a xbox shilling
your xbox is corporate lawyer now hey
hogue i'm a playstation guy and i get
that so oh
it isn't my fault look playstation has
had like four messaging stories in a row
that aren't great i'm more than happy to
cover the times at xboxes and i have
when i try to double the price of gold
we did a video oh yeah so
that's what i'm about okay but in any
event i love you guys thank you for
inviting me i'm gonna get out of here
get some food enjoy your sunday a
pleasure rick hogue of the whole
business law firm subscribe to channels
in there enjoy your sunday brother
always a pleasure thank you iron lords
you already know absolutely salute you
know big cloud ran i'm just making sure
guys are okay i have to ask because
friends excuse me of keeping people
hostage so if people have things i'm not
kicking anybody out steven that's the
great thing about not being on camera so
you don't know what i'm doing oh
[Laughter]
all right just uh give me a second no
worries
no worries refreshing
there's a lot oh god oh god because he
was going at home yeah
station dudes it's gonna fail i told you
it's gonna fail you're not getting
called dude it's done they get call of
duty though you know
and if you think anybody got enough
money to pay any senators well
[Music]
[Laughter]
quick question
you read the one where he was talking
about
three guys got ps three games to run on
an emulator on pc
that earlier yes
we got we got a two dollar stream from
michael patton uh
uh so
xbox versus cycle is an 87 medical is
that a game yep we we got that one
okay ten dollar superstar from jj
first off mlb yeah we took and we took
your game xbox till we die
we came equipped with flames yeah jim
ryan don't mess with real g's we click
to snatch our dancing butt off the
streets whoa
baby
that is the sagittarius
very aggressive
it continues
got
a uh superchat from gamma onyx
uh game pass ultimate is nine in india
xbox announced it's going down to
six point
eight one okay dollars by the end of
april here that's cool
uh we got a two dollar super trap from
criminalistic
chrono test
clone artistic
remember xbox steam any device ps5 only
console
five dollars from tech money won't sony
be the leader in subscription services
starting in june what yeah kill the game
pass monopoly argument yeah that they'll
definitely be the leader to the trash
can oh you know it's funny i actually i
actually asked we could have asked that
the hug when he was here which question
about like
does
them announcing uh the new ps plus
revamp
inadvertently help microsoft's position
with game pass for the activision deal
and he said uh that it might be the
opposite it actually might hurt it it
actually might hurt microsoft because
he said like you'd have to find out how
many people are subscribed to the 15
tier like
like the ftc might decide and say hey
you are stopping sony and other people
from entering this thing so it is a
monopoly or you know so that we we
should ask we should have asked him that
yeah we should after that for sure i
forgot about that maybe hold make a
video a five dollar super chat from jd
gamer hogan is there any way oh you
already answered that uh then we got the
one from uh kid smooth uh for whole
could square unix sells crystal dynamics
to microsoft in the middle of all this
10 hours super uh five dollar superstar
from uh michael payton i've said what
attic is asking before spin tango off
bethesda into xbox japan absorb and buy
uh japanese entities in that way and
grow it organically are
uh hogue is a huge asset to the
community thank you and i think we have
like two more refresh
we have a five dollar shot
what days are you guys going to be here
for pax would love to hang out we'll be
there oh you're in boston bro yeah we'll
be there we'll be there
i don't know what day is it thursday
through the saturday we'll be there
every day thursday to saturday the only
day without this or sunday
cool we good and and that's all folks
all right cool you know i gotta i got a
question for for for uh big cloud oh so
my guy
you know i i you know i've been kind of
taking a sabbatical from social media
here and there right i haven't released
a video in a while
i don't really get on twitter i don't
really tweet right but that's all
changing soon enough months
i guess but uh i could have i could have
sworn i saw a bunch of playstation guys
being like sony's about to buy from
software and konami this week there was
supposed to be like
big playstation news that was gonna
happen wednesday and then on wednesday
was going to happen thursday but then
maybe it's just like adapting with the
wind yeah so what happened so what
happened what was going on
i don't even know that's the thing i
heard jeff grubsley um something big was
happening and then greg miller added his
take on it i was okay cool and then now
i got people saying wb
got two seconds from software i got dude
saying
um because gm productions i'm like okay
um sure um
[Laughter]
i don't know it just seemed it seemed to
me because people were sending me tweets
and it was just like i felt like it was
a bunch of people who like wanted to be
want to be insiders
or like quoting that like sending out
like i emoji tweets and then if sony did
announce something they could be like
see i knew to me
i knew what was going on no you didn't
you know how it is you see it multiple
times uh whenever you're right about
something or somebody else is right
about something then you know these
dudes just don't like that they want to
replicate that and see if they can get
the same thing that's just what they
want attractions
and
it just it's going to be a lot of that
yeah
we'll see how it goes with what actually
happens you know i want to know who who
says oh i was the first one to say there
wasn't gonna be a playstation six
i don't care you can make all the rumors
you want playstation fanboys because i'm
gonna make all the videos i wanna got
your room
[Laughter]
move it on let's get these last two out
man this one is a big one kind of just
dropped this week in uh undead lab
allegations like kataku had came out
with an article
allegations of sexism bullying and
burnout inside the microsoft studio
behind state of decay 3.
very long article talking about
potential mistreatment talking about hr
talking about studio head
um jeff strain at one point the other uh
successor i believe hope was the
gentleman's name
and um yeah we had that going on and
obviously the talk of potential
mismanagement and state of the case
cycle then what was interesting was the
day before the article dropped jeff
strain himself came out with a medium
post and what's funny is there's
actually supposed to come out that day
right for some reason the real article
got done got delayed so he came out and
then he made a whole post kind of say
hey this something's about to come out
almost like a hit piece in reference to
undead labs at his time there and he had
a lot to say
you know in reference to you know undead
labs what his contribution was
what his personal situation was and so
on and so forth so this has brought a
lot of questions and um i want to get
let's start ranting this because you
know
there's there's there's a there's a rule
of thought here there's some some
different types of thinking here which
is one is like
okay
some people say hey
we really like the fact that jeff got in
front of this right he really got in
front of it and dispelled a hit piece
and he gave his facts and then other
people on this other side that says look
mismanagement at microsoft once again
another first party game
using shambles and what the hell is and
and and
you alluded to it a little bit with xbox
too and i also want to talk about it
which is just knows more about this
whole situation yeah jazz don't know i
know a little so i ain't no i don't
dress love but i do know a little
something but you know the the mindset
of
hands on
microsoft crack the whip get in there
you know
control your own ship or be hands off
microsoft you know which is look we
allow the studios to create what they
want to create and maybe we'll step in
if things get crazy but we're not going
to be in the process i want to get two
part questions what do you think about
the stuff all this that happened
and that hands-on hands-off stuff
yeah i mean like
i think there was a lot of criticism of
xbox um previous generations that they
were too hands-on that they stifled
creativity
and i think part of microsoft's pitch to
some of these obsidians and ninja
theories of the world about being
acquired was like listen we're gonna be
hands off you just make what you want
and that's a good pitch like you got our
backing
uh we're not gonna really meddle into
your day-to-day business we want you to
remain you know remain have your culture
remain and it works for for for
companies that have a very good strong
leadership like over at ninja theory
obsidian playground and stuff like that
that works fine microsoft can basically
just write the check and that's it and
they'll make the games right uh but for
some uh
maybe that's a little need a firmer hand
like
from what my basic understanding of the
whole undead labs thing was
jeff's focus was elsewhere after the
buyout right and he hired somebody and
that somebody
maybe wasn't a good hire and was
hiding things or whatever or like cause
of some some problems that i think like
eventually made it up to microsoft and
they kind of
they basically got rid of the person
right and i think even the end of the
article says that they feel like the
company is in better position because i
think they went from like 60 people at
state in undead labs before the
acquisition to like 120 so they doubled
right um because they were going from
double a to like aaa with state of the
k3
and obviously they ran into some
problems but what this really kind of
does is people take these individual
cases so they they take this undead labs
case
and they try to link it to the
initiative
they try to link it to what hap what's
going on with ever wild at rare division
deal
not even the activision deal then they
try to link it to the halo infinite 343
and like so they say look at these four
look at these cases this is proof that
mike there's a problem at microsoft
rather than like this is individual
problems that'll be fixed you know
without microsoft's intervention or with
microsoft's intervention
uh but like nobody like nobody reads or
nobody
reads deeper than the headlines so the
narratives built that microsoft has an
issue and microsoft has problems and
they should be more
uh more involved and i do agree if you
have problems like that were stated that
undead labs like sexism and bullying
right
yeah if if if you as a company can't
handle it yourself and
get out that that bad person then yeah
microsoft should step in and be like no
because how because one of the things
with the whole activision oh i guess
like what big cloud was saying is like
if you can't really
solve undead labs with 120 employees how
are you going to solve and cleanse
activision blizzard with 10 000
employees and has a worse history right
right yeah so there's that to think
about but for some of it it's you know a
lot of people like the console war like
oh you know the initial like i think
these things are separate yeah it's
these things separate like the
initiative was like they wanted to build
a game in a different way they hired all
these people
uh that really didn't work together and
that way of making a game like it didn't
work they were having problems and it
was like okay we're gonna make the game
this way and those people are like well
i didn't sign up for do that so i'm
leaving right but it does paint the
picture and some and i mean you have
talked about a cog like right perception
is reality yes for some people yep so
for this this perception is that xbox
has an issue and the only way to really
solve that issue is
state of the k3 whenever it comes out
it's gotta be good gotta be fine that's
what i tell people
that comes out gotta be good yeah the
only way you're gonna shut up like the
haters is by putting out an exceptional
product yep yeah no i agree with i agree
with you with the hands-off approach um
but i also agree with fonz and chat like
i think that should be a case-by-case
spaces rim especially with
at the state of decay 2 as i'm saying i
would literally
keep my eye on these guys
[Laughter]
part three
what do you mean because theta k2 wasn't
a good game or because quality wise it
wasn't
uh i don't think it made the impact
i don't i can't really 100 percent get
out on that now i will agree with you
steady decay 2 should have been a
different game than it was what about
skill but they gave scale about another
chance they developed
the thing is is like
i think microsoft takes stuff on what it
is like we don't ex we we never really
invested money for stated k2 to be a
different game so they can't really
expect a different type of quality on a
game when they're not giving the quality
type of budgeting to make that game a
better game
well you know you know you know big
cloud like microsoft must like them
enough they bought the studio right
right so
yeah true but i mean like you just said
earlier before it's
we got to see i wouldn't even before we
really say that well right but i would
rather have i'm i'm a fan of the course
fred made some games you know you got
people out there buying companies that
didn't make a game talking about it just
pre-ordering remember which is
pre-ordering
but also you know jay raymond has a
track record she's worked on something
yeah
i am a fan of corporations being hands
off in the creative process
so i mean sony's typically that way and
i think sony greens
most nine times out of ten are amazing
yeah uh so like that was the rag
microsoft got was that they were too
invested and too close and it kind of
stifled creativity so right i'd rather
than be hands off but so in these in
this case like state of decay it's like
you need to get rid of the person that's
causing problems right
yeah yeah which it seemed that the hr
situation
and people felt that their voices
weren't being heard and it looks like
you know that person is no longer there
and then yeah like i said like you said
um i'll go last i'll be right back okay
cool yeah like like you said you know um
at the end of the day uh i'll jump
better if i can't i can't get a chance
to go before i talk oh king like what's
your thoughts on this man
like here we go again
okay okay here we go again okay we give
them something to talk about you know
and everybody needs something to talk
about to push the narrative because
there's no news going on over there so
you know hey you know
what i don't like is but you know
isolated incidents turns into uh you
know huge things now if it's if it's uh
um like a group of people
doing these things and it's affecting
groups of people um then you have a
problem with that uh
that that company yeah and that company
needs to have turnover
you know um you have to go in there you
have to gut out you know the bad apples
and you know fix the situation um
again until all information is actually
known correct you know uh we don't sit
there and pass judgment now on on a lot
of cases we knew
of a lot of stuff people died
of uh in cases that uh you know these
things was going around with the
pictures and the activation
stuff like that so um
again i i until everything is out and i
i hope that the individual it no longer
works there right
like rand said when the game comes out
they have to make a quality game because
at the end of the day where we play
video games we don't play politics and
what goes on inside a company so i
believe that um
if microsoft needs to
step in and go down there to figure out
exactly what's going on with the you
know the developer
they will do so but again this is
another little black eye a little little
little bump
a little mosquito bite on on their
resume again because you know you got
the 343 then you have the initiative
then you have this and you have that and
there's all these questions now before
they're hands on and oh you know they
they're going to foster
they're telling people what to do you
know they they don't let them be
creative and now they'll you know let
the inmates run the asylum so it's like
okay what is it
like
what is it you know what what's what's
happening
i honestly believe that isolated
incidents
and you know and you can't compare
apples to oranges one situation is one
thing another situation is another what
i do know is
being that we're in the western market
and i believe the transparencies in
microsoft and the philosophies that we
have in the western area
is different than in the eastern market
where they're a little bit more
tight-lipped everything is done inside
house and unless
you catch a dude with a camera yeah and
you know barely getting these things
listen listen at his front door oh yeah
he was
exactly i'm gonna be rude too so um but
this is no alleges right so you guys got
video you got video on that right so
unless it's situations like that we
don't hear anything right right until
somebody comes out years later and they
tell a tell-all book that they was
working at some company to some black
ops company that was inside there that
was doing games in the background and
they was held tight and they couldn't
make games uh for something else because
they had to be a backup studio remember
so again
these things don't get out over here
they get out over here because microsoft
is a little bit more transparent and i
believe it's our culture in the western
market that we need to know everything
and that stuff does leak out and that
stuff does you know permeate you know
the air so now for your attic is going
to go or jump in yeah okay look this is
how this is how i think okay
i agree with
pretty much both i agree with all of you
you know here's the caveat i think
though
uh i do feel like
the hands-off thing needs to be
restructured a little bit like until you
prove that you don't need us interfering
with your stuff i'm not saying like like
hover over them but i'm saying monitor
you know what i'm saying
i'm not saying
but put a camera in the room
it's just like you know it's like
i'm not saying that i'm saying to the
point it's like okay
obsidian's good i only got to visit them
every three or four months you know what
frequency or visit okay you know another
studio that you know hasn't proved that
they don't need that hands off i'll
visit them every two months
so it's just like i don't necessarily
because
i think it's
how often you visit in 314
every other week
where's 343 located uh they're on
they're in the redmond campus
you go visit them every day
you know
like look look we're not going to get
into like clowning because we've done
plenty
but it's just like look like a few of
these studios you know i do feel like
you because here's the thing like
regardless if you feel like it it
attacks creativity that does to a point
but sometimes that's good for the studio
uh you know they put a trace in and got
a war that wasn't going to happen unless
there was input from the top right it's
like you know i i he didn't tell him to
do it but he said i feel like there's
something missing go back to the drawing
board corey barlow has never came out
and said he was forced to do that right
he said i didn't sense
the excitement from him so he found
something else to put in the game right
and when he came back he's like this is
it this is the game like that's so
that's all i'm saying it's like some of
these studios i do feel like you know
you you might need to be popping in
there be like yo let me see what you got
you gotta you gotta build like but i
don't want it to i don't wanna you gotta
build it
yeah let me see this newest build man
let me see your newest build why are you
putting people on the spot man why you
gotta why they gotta present their
homework
you make a game and i'm not even saying
it's got to be like a mad successful
game just a game
how far would we fit you you have a
t-shirt yo let me see you wear your
building take your build out
so so what you know and once you've
proved that you know you're a studio
that doesn't need a total hands-on then
you know the next game they make you
give them a better budget you give them
more people and you know you might you
might pop in there every six months
you guys you know all you have little
things that flash up on the side like
bend the mean alert and stuff you need
to have one that says show me your show
me your build bro
so
that that's that one that's that one
that's how i feel about the hands-on
thing because i do feel like certain
studios i don't want a blanket thing
attacking every studio because i feel
like some studios have earned the right
that like you know
i don't want them attacking their
creativity but i do want them i think
the biggest thing that we're here seeing
here is
is
what's that they call that tunnel vision
where it's like you know and outside
and outside what's what i'm looking for
an outside perspective sometimes we'll
get these people back on a better a
better role than they were before that
uh but you know
i we have to see at the end of the day i
you when you own 30 plus studios you
know obviously right now they don't know
what they're playing you're going to
have a lot of studios that's not on
track you're it's just how it is like
right i don't think this even with the
three studies that we have now like you
know the initiative
um undead labs and 343 like i don't
necessarily think that that is saying
all of the studios are failing that's
like some studios need you know they
need a show they build
[Laughter]
what's you know once i feel like i feel
like that that's that's the one thing i
want to point like i don't want them to
go in there
and disrupt creativity i just want them
to go in there and just check on the
work yeah where are you at that's where
you at without your videos yeah and then
well uh and then you know i feel like
what rand was saying is spot on it is
a perception thing yes you know
regardless if it's just three like i
said you got 25 30 plus studios
you you need to have the sensation that
like all these studios at any time can
be looked at from anyone right and i do
feel like that you know once they saw
the initiative thing three four three
dropping the ball a little bit with
three uh with halo
now you have low-key witch hunt going
around where people are looking for more
stories to add to the xbox right you
can't
look you know this is great discussion a
lot of stuff um there's a part of me
that's what king is just like you know
there is a part of me
if you're a mets fans i'm a [ __ ] face
like
here we go again right it's like it's
like just when the season's about to
start look promising
you get the injury to jacob the crime he
might be out there you know so it's like
it to me it's all xbox always has that
little bit of energy where things always
seem to go right you know they always
see something that seems to happen that
goes left where things should be
appearing to go right so look this is
what i would say you know
with this situation it's tough for me
because look i am full disclosure i am
biased i love undead labs you know um i
love state of decay you want to
encourage bad behavior no i do not
encourage that behavior but i will say
you're funny that's a good one
i will say that you know at the end of
the day you know i i'm pulling for them
right i'm always going to pull for i
know a lot of people in that building
what i will say is this what i thought
was interesting is
strain jumping out ahead i've i've never
really seen that which is a pre-emptive
strike to like yo
kataku or somebody gonna put an article
about us and me you know i mean and i
want to give you my side and let's be
honest you know what that feels like
that feels like
i'm gonna fix this before it interrupts
my current background right and let's be
honest a lot of a lot of devs
who knows what the reason is but a lot
of devs you know they don't put
themselves out there because you put
yourself out there you're gonna be
subject to criticism and people are
gonna analyze and break that stuff down
a zillion times so this is what i can
speak to what i can speak to is i know
for a fact the part about
his personal situation i've known that
for a while i've known that he was
traveling from he's based out of new
orleans and he was traveling from new
orleans to washington i mean right where
they are you know to run that studio
right so it's something for him that's
not most likely going to be sustainable
on a personal level i do also know that
the part that he's talking about about
them having
uh
kind of like an academy it was like an
undead labs academy it was almost think
of it like it was like a developer
feeder system thing that was going to be
based out of new orleans where he's from
you know that cooperates with his story
too i remember when microsoft and then
put out the press statement saying that
they're going to have this undead labs
thing and so on and so forth you know i
do also remember rand when the
announcement in their strife jeff strain
was lazy leaving very concerned i was
like what is going on so i'm trying to
find out what's going on this book i
care so much about this game i want this
game to succeed i always feel love
undead i love undead i love state of
decay it's
just such an amazing game and i think
what it is cog is
we love the foundation steady case built
on we like imagine what's exactly the
reason why i love everybody look it's
janky and big cloud you're absolutely i
know where you're going right i'm not
going to discount the warts and the
issue i still to this day wanted to put
a bullet through my head when you can't
have more than four people go around a
square block because of the because of
the tethering of the co-op but i will
say this like the potential of that game
with a budget with proper direction
could be special there's a reason why
it's emerging
but the gameplay about it is this like
so when he leaves now i go oh no like
what's going on in there you know what
i'm saying and for what i've been told
you know what i mean like nah
it's family it's family that's all it is
it's not you know anything whatever now
whether or not you want to say the
transition of power was held smoothly
that could be up for debate whether or
not the hr and stuff allegations and
stuff like that that is clearly up no
one's here condoning abuse sexism we're
not condoning that right from what was
left in place sort of transition and
also people have to understand when new
people are in power this is the thing
strange said no on in his piece that i
really resonated with which is that when
you're in that pre-production you're in
that yo you know what'll be cool if we
do phase
right when you in that phase so if
you're the leader you're like okay this
would be cool this would be cool leader
leaves new leader comes in
this is what will be cool for me i don't
like anything
so now you've got a group of people and
devs who were initially with
jeff strange's this is what would be
cool
so now they get the nude marching orders
of what
holt or whoever's want to be cool and
they'd be like
nah fam that ain't it now you throw that
in conjunction with potential sexism
abuse women not getting hurt or what
have you again i'm not in that building
i cannot say for certain what has
happened this is definitive no one knows
that part but i do know that there will
be people that's like yo that's not the
vision that i wanted or that they're
going to go and they're going to like
why are you on that god what do you what
exactly are you like um expecting
in general from yeah from the like
steady for me are you expecting from
what we saw on that trailer the cgi with
the d i mean what can we really say
like
the article comes out to say according
to taco's article that they kind of
scrapped to get that microsoft did come
by on the check-in and said look we got
ebay
they did not say that but they did say
hey if you get away they say hey if you
have something
we would like to have something showed
for the e3 showcase and i heard a little
trailer was spliced together by them in
the 11th hour and internally they might
not have been
ready to even do that but the powers
that be pushed at right so that's why
they did this in the middle of pandemic
right so
but i'm not making no excuses like at
the end of the day here's the thing and
i see shout out to fawns in the chat
going hard here's the problem
no one cares
no one cares no one hearing no one want
to hear about what's going on all they
want to know is when is this game coming
is it going to be fire oh microsoft got
problems internally microsoft don't know
how to make that's the talk
so until they produce the bangers and
until these games that are underneath
these conditions produce they are going
to continue to hear it so what i'm with
attic now is like yo
it may be
for these cases with the
rare with the everwild with 343 with not
producing enough content you know post
halo launch or whatever whatever
maybe right it's microsoft's job to say
okay let me now step in now because
clearly there's some issues here or
whatever whatever but again overall
i am with ran like i prefer
creativity preserved i preserve you go
in there do what you got to do now there
has to be a balance checks and balances
okay like to add explain we are we at
this delivery where's your build on on
the 19th where what's going on here
maybe maybe they have to figure that
part out but i will say this last point
i have to say this last point and it's
the part that's getting me a little
frustrated with a certain group of
fanboys we have to stop acting like just
because a game is a banger that that
absolves it from toxic work culture that
absolves it that they have no problems
making deliverable people understand
game development is extremely difficult
sometimes these games do not land until
the 11th hour of a project right so we
got to stop like there's only one way to
do it and the
these groups know how to do it all the
way we've seen the stories we've seen
great companies that made bangers don't
exist anymore so
it's it's it's so many variables in this
business to just say it's a cut and dry
and all you got to do and all you got to
do that's not how game development works
it's still a crap shoot there's still a
lot of factors on it that's all i'm
saying no one is in the building in
every case i say all that to say this at
the end of the day
these games
got to be bangers because if they're not
people who are going to point
exactly they say you see we said and
that's where i give the perception as
reality people their due because they
got to execute it yeah like because we
like we're not flyers in the world
in these offices we don't know what's
happening right so seeing is really the
believing type of thing
we see with our eyes that's how we do it
yeah absolutely
that's what i said like yo
you know i'm like i'm with you like
creativity is definitely there
um
there should be like a a leeway at some
points where we gotta go some studios
and you know you know what's the track
record right you know what i mean that's
what it is bro you know what the good
part about this big cloud i like yeah is
sometimes you do need a spotlight to
happen for big bro to come in and say
you know what maybe we got to adjust our
policy maybe completely hands-off ain't
the way maybe they're learning through
this we don't know all i know is they
got they got to put out a good product
if they want to stop the talk
so so what do you pick up you pick up
the booty phone and booty answers the
phone and says show me your build
bootyman
show me your build month
we're going to need some updates we
might need an update maybe maybe like
attic
i mean
in big cloud it's like maybe certain
people like bethesda are afforded that
we don't check in addict said it broke
beautifully yeah you buy a house yeah
like you know
exactly
like god howard is like bro you know how
our bills do you know what i'm saying
sorry
it comes down to track record and maybe
when you do the newer guy like i know
minecraft people won't know what's up
because you would think you know after
the three four three the power rangers
you wouldn't wanna you would avoid all
that
like that's what i'm saying and you
wanna avoid this conversation it's a
good point i think 343 has been a victim
of mismanagement for a very very long
time
yeah i think that's
mismanagement and i think pandemic just
completely hit them in the face like
they got they got spear bombs straight
out the ring which you
know do you really halo's call for
delays let's keep it a bug it's like man
you know if 343 should be i don't even
really think of 343 as even one of
microsoft's top
10 studios they have at the time
and it's a shame because they actually
they they make like
their biggest game their biggest ip
i like that
i mean i love halo i'm just saying
i think 343 has been mismanaged for
quite some time no that's fair that's
fair but we got to be fair too we we're
doing it we we can't act like
coalition ain't been holding it down
coalition
we can't act like hold on hold on hold
on we can't actually
thank you so much
i'm not coming for rand i meant to say
just overall like because again
perception sometimes tries to bleed into
reality and people have to act like
everything is a problem that that's not
the whole school if you look at every
single situation it's not everybody's
misimagined it's all this doom and gloom
situation we have they just won
publisher of of the year metacritic at
the highest rated last year so we we
can't pooh-pooh this like there's this
oh my god every studio they have they
mismanaged and they're all hands off and
everything's a problem
no but i don't think i don't want to
said that i'm seeing it i mean i mean
we're seeing that
like that we see the echo people that
don't really have any say on anything
and they don't really know
but the thing is i'll give people on
twitter the perception there is a
perception that it looks bad but if but
that the perception
i feel like would be more accurate if
xbox had like eight studios and three or
four of them were messing up right but
they don't they got a drastically more
studios than that so clearly you're
gonna have issues you're not gonna
you're never gonna have all these
studios
exactly you see okay no such thing all
right
90 percent of the time you see this this
is where the hypocrisy comes in
because i smell it and it's permeating
the air
right but we don't get a chance to hear
what's going on with horizon
i'm surprised you can feel anything in
the air with that jacket
you feel everything cause your nipples
is out
[Laughter]
y'all gotta stop y'all step on fire at
each other i love it
hey with that jacket dude
it keeps
[Laughter]
yourself right now how the hell he know
my nipples is out
to look i just want tips for you to like
how can i look as good as you do yeah
i want the gold i want the chains i want
the jacket you look like this
you look at the spaces that's up right
now they made the spaces about the
jacket so you can figure out how much
you did oh my god well that made his
face just like eight months ago and you
ain't never gonna let that go no hell no
listen like like what i'm saying is
what's in the air the hypocrisy is in it
i want to know what the hell went wrong
with gran turismo
i want to know what went wrong with
horizon okay you see but we're not
getting that information elden ring went
wrong with all right no no you can't say
eldon ring went wrong because eldon ring
didn't make it a broken game
oh you know eldon elderweight just came
out
yeah
you know it's superior but then you're
talking about a 70 game
that came out and it was buggy
developer king but
i'm not supposed to change
sony you're not getting innovation pink
sony told you that they need that 70 to
have quality products but then you got
the 70 where's the quality this is this
is what i'm talking about and i'm saying
i'm telling you what i say on boom show
when you when you increase the price of
anything what gets bigger that
magnifying glass and you look what
you're uh no it was the same see this is
the problems and y'all y'all keep
overlooking it because y'all want to
point the finger over it oh you know
three four three didn't deliver this
right
hand
i'm talking about the games from the
superior product
we don't hear
what went wrong that's a good point
and i want to know what went wrong but i
will say this to sony's credit
they keep that on the ground bro ain't
nobody snitching it down
[Laughter]
we have headquarters in every country we
can hide your body yeah
when everybody was asking what is going
on with eternal
maternal dev came out and said it's not
us
it's stemmed
and they got hurt
what's that what's that star wars saying
king like order 1866
they're like they hit the order 66
button all i know is sony is strong
outside as far as
media pr
review codes
coverage sony is strong you know what
i'm saying and they they run a tight
ship so i get running a tight ship just
like they run uh
they run censorship like crazy they sent
to reviewers talking about their games
they said
you're talking about that game is is the
nba game is though that that game is
real and and though
is so strong
regardless uh
yeah at the end of the day you know i i
personally love microsoft's transparency
me personally but this is one of the
situations why i have to give this
culture that that yeah like this is
where sometimes it does come back to
bite not that i don't want them to jump
ahead of stuff not that i don't want
them talking because we appreciate them
when they do but this is where it does
sometimes come back to bite them because
we know so much like oh okay this that
the third but it is what it is look we
got to move on let's get this last time
because dutch is accusing us saying
we're going along and we said he wasn't
so you want to get the um
chat super chats there oh mr addict sir
yes uh just keep going uh i'll get the
rest of the super chats at the end
because yeah it's a lot okay yeah
you gotta tune in every sunday because i
got 15 more jackets to go
more spaces talk
look final one man i appreciate this is
a good one
e3
e3 2022
digital and physical officially been
canceled esa has confirmed the
cancellation
so news broke from razer pr lead will
power said that an email has been sent
out announcing the cancellation of the
digital event it looks like i shot the
idea and put out this story said they
def uh independently verified the
contents of the email so yeah so um they
were talking about a potential digital
equivalent but without strong momentum
to drive them the esa now update seems
to plan make plans to regroup for a
larger
comeback in 2023 esc has esa has shared
an official statement with ign
confirming the 22 current cancellation
2022 and announcing that e3 will return
in 2023 with a quote
reinvigorate
showcase
so
what do we think yeah
real quick
i just brought it up there's only like
eight you want me just go and read them
real quick before we do it yeah let's
get them let's get him because i feel
like let's get him i'd rather go more
than 30.
let's get it let's get it
um so we got a five dollar subject from
don otaku why don't sony recent
allegations make the headlines though
even though somnic had a big thing that
no one talked about i don't know about
that uh you know uh that that's that's
up to the media to cover we ain't the me
uh we two dollar super chat from forza
legends they didn't get two was a good
game i agree i think it needed to
improve but it was definitely a good
game uh two dollar super chat from uh
from says
microsoft doesn't seem to invest in
people-only products
we got a student jeff from dan lorenzo i
got 900 hours in state of decay 2
zip how dare you talk about the great
state of the crate too that's what they
felt we got a five dollar super he said
he's a don't you put great luxury of
playing uh broken games
that's you dude you play horizon oh my
god
[Music]
um
did you play return
all right so so we got to find out from
lady stan one of the great things about
microsoft is that they don't mix uh
micromanage their employees no org is
perfect but
uh no organization is perfect but
microsoft is number one in the company
culture even with flaws that's true
[Laughter]
what if the acquisition turns require
xbox to not interfere okay
uh then we got a ten dollar super chat
from jj
we talking oh
we take it
we take it so many women for xbox and
chill mess with xbox and get your caps
pill
last game you shot but kill but don't
didn't kill us now you've got to fail
with the wrath of a menace xbox hit him
up
yo we're doing
[Laughter]
how many great games does xbox have to
put out before it is considered enough
they're already delivering many but
apparently it isn't enough
would you uh would just like to get a
threshold that can be measured well
metacritic says they enough and jim ryan
says you not enough
and i'm not i i look look people keep
twisting that word i didn't say that you
know i'm saying that when they
consistently make the kind of quality
games that you know is out regularly
like their studios their actual studios
like when you see fable come out like
that's what i'm saying a valve fable
perfect dart like you know star filled
with those games start coming out
because those are the big titles like
let's be real here people don't consider
the smaller titles they're sure they're
fun to play but no one talks about them
to that degree let's be honest here
right uh we got a two dollar super trap
from flame i can't ran said the studios
need a booty call
he didn't say that red didn't say that
one i've got five dollars troop shark
one one bad mother iop and all today's
guests have a strong bill keep doing it
my build is strong
right here
[Laughter]
oh that needs to be a shirt that needs
to be your shirt oh that's you building
over here
we got a we got a five dollar super chat
donald talker so y'all just
see you you all ain't just see the
sexual uh harassment allegations a week
ago from sony yes media hit that one
real quick okay i i don't even remember
that i do remember i know
that's probably the tweet that that's
probably the point of the super chat i
don't remember it
uh five dollar supervisor from lady sand
this is addressed to you cog oh car you
need to stop with this sony's credit
let's call it out as it is sony is a
marketing company that manipulates its
base and it's media how do you respond
to that call but did you see they build
though
[Laughter]
all they build is up front with it
they'd be up front you can't front on
them
oh
then we gotta find all those troopers
from dj or
you need to hit us up man where you been
no e3 or well gcx still there oh also
hey besties
[Music]
that's my hobby right there what's going
on dj i hope you're all right brother
everything good you know what you know
one thing i do have that's really good
is a good building
well we caught up we go all right cool
so it was up i think i was leaving it to
rain they saying it's not dead now new
update so it's dead
it's dead it's not coming back they said
reinvigorated
reinvigorate
nobody needs these i mean
in this day and age you don't
necessarily need e3 like
i know it sucks because like we all have
a lot of fond memories of watching it on
you know uh e4 like our computers or on
tv or actually being there right and
like
experiencing it and stuff it's very
nostalgic
but
uh
i don't think the esa is the leadership
to kind of
come back from not doing it for a couple
years at this point especially when you
have all these publishers have been
doing their own shows being like why do
we need to pay for pay you pay for floor
space when
we just
fly people out if we want to to play our
games or
you know like do our own show like it's
dead i'm sorry i i mean
i don't know it's it's it's an end of an
era
and i don't know the kiwi thing like i
like what keeley's trying to do but like
summer games fest if i remember
correctly last year was just like
it was more like an indie it was like
summer ad fest
you know even with the video game awards
it's just like ads ads ads trailers
well yeah i know you got to get paid but
yeah we had this conversation before
yeah we have
so
so i mean they fronting it's over
yeah i mean i guess this kind of opens
up like
companies like xbox not to be beholden
to like
we are only having the one show and it's
only going to be doing june you know
what i mean like i don't think that's
going anywhere i'm gonna be real i think
i think well no they they are hiring
somebody to like kind of
do more uh with that job listing from a
couple months ago because i do
they're guarding more shows
they're gonna do more shows but
i don't think like as far as like the
big big announcements i don't think
that's changing like they're going to do
more shows because they're clearly
bringing on activision uh they have all
these studios that you know
theoretically should have
news in the next year so i feel like
that's why they're trying to do more
events but as far as like that big
middle of the year show i don't think
that's changing
what you think so i i'm gonna ask
randy's before i open it up a bit um
do you think because i've had this
conversation with maddie because of all
the acquisitions and now we had whole
you know maybe we're looking at maybe 70
30 80 20 the activision microsoft deal
does happen
with all that
do you think they can afford to just do
only one show
you know because of the because that's
technically all the kind of they can't
no they can't they got they got too many
games coming in in the future where
one show wouldn't suffice it anymore
so are going to need more this is like
eight hours long
like you're going to need a show for
you're basically going to need a show in
the for every publisher you need you'll
need a show at the end of the year like
which there still might be like two
shows this year you might get your e3
show whatever you know spring summer
showcase and then you prob an xo right
yeah maybe an xo with an audience
because i know phil's big fan of
you know those those
like imagine the bethesda announcement
being announced at like an e3 and how
like
crazy the crowd would have gone for that
or whatever right yeah um
or the announcement of fable coming back
because remember remember when addict
doubted that fable was coming back
and well i mean because you guys are
telling me for three years
i don't know when microsoft's going to
review this stuff
it's coming out since eventually that's
true
for like three years
but you know those announcements would
have went over like people would have
went crazy
um so i i do think microsoft will do
like
physical events in the future maybe more
geared towards xo but
they're definitely gonna have to do more
because they're gonna they got
15 xbox game studios they got
eight or nine studios with bethesda
right they got all the studios with the
activision i mean they they ha they own
quakecon now right like
blizzcon and think about this
like i'm trying to tell the manual to
find a duke like
you know people don't want to hear this
but when you own
activision
call of duty got to get a spot bro
like when you when you announced the bad
thing about it exactly people people
fail to realize that guess what the
candy crush and
all them games got to get a spot on the
show
because you own them whether or not
they're on other platforms or not
they have to be on their platform to
advertise the new content here's the new
zombies usually i mean
unless gamescom is going to be the the
new oasis and they'll just branch that
out i mean we're ready we're ready for
that game it's called we want to fly out
speaking of e3 uh so
so this right here this one hurts man
this is this is a lot of us man this is
where
we we all tuned in this is the super
bowl for us all for gaming uh to see it
go it i know a lot of people again brand
as part of the group a lot of them are
saying that you know it's not needed
anymore we we're we're so past it
because you know back then we had only
one avenue to really get us there and
that was g4 network yeah we had them you
know we online but we read the articles
but
personally i mean
it sucks because like all you see
everybody else adapting you see the game
awards getting to where they are and
then they're moving around and they're
making it more accessible to gamers you
know i mean different locations you
would think they would do the same thing
over there the committee with the um
with e3 maybe add themes to it you know
i'm treated like that at wrestlemania
that's something
i missed i didn't do nothing you know i
mean they did nothing uh with this and
it sucks and
you know i get i get approved for pax
and here we go i know this happens i'm
like
really yeah like i was really hoping
like this would be the start you know
going into it maybe not this year i
wouldn't be able to go right but
hopefully that will lead to something
next year and there'll be more interest
and people would you know
go into this some of you know some of
the most amazing moments in gaming
e3 with the hardware reveals like the
ps4
we got review and microsoft doing this
at like shows that
a lot of us wouldn't even consider
flagship shows for hardware reveals
microsoft had the xbox reveal at the
cable awards here goes sony doing this
in the digital event has just about much
of a big reaction
as they did when they had the ps4 so
it's like
sony pulled out
way even earlier they pulled out three
years ago for they pulled out in 2019
from e3 like they've been saying e3 is
dead for
a while now right yeah they were saving
the money for bungie
got to save those coins
you're ridiculous
but not
that was funny that was funny as hell
i agree though um ran it's
let me let me i'll show you this soul
died of it you know that's not whatever
did you ever get to go
to either no yeah
i never i really won you know who killed
e3 um
[Music]
no you know what listen ryan
it it was losing its soul
sure the moment they let the people in
oh
oh
yeah or elitist talk
no i'm serious because it was disgusting
to me
i look over at this guy he's standing
online and his girlfriend is standing
there with a face and i don't want to be
here i didn't leave
and leave because you're sitting here
poo pooing on your man's fun right now
if you ain't if you ain't 100 behind
don't show up
because this this is our super bowl this
is our situation and and
i saw a lot of tagger owns i i saw a lot
of plus ones
you know and
dudes playing a game and somebody's
tapping them on the shoulder hey man how
about uh i want to go over if you don't
get away from me i stood on this line
for seven hours to get to see zelda if
you don't get away from me
um it's just
they stopped giving away stuff
and started selling stuff
reed walked in and the more people that
they saw there that was the casual
people the candy crush people
yeah you know they wanted to buy socks
when we was giving socks before
you know so again
the moment they opened the doors and saw
that they can make a buck that was the
moment the soul left
yeah the moment that vip wrote down to
talk with a developer and have that time
but you had to be slotted into time and
you only have 15 20 minutes
it became disgusting to me you were
shoulder to shoulder like he was at
great adventures
oh yeah
if you're walking through the convention
center shoulder to shoulder with those
peasants
i don't care i don't care who feels bad
about it oh he's keeping the bucket
though he's standing over here don't get
me started with those special badges
where do you just walk right past you
all the way to the front
listen let me tell you something that
part right there that part that great
adventure part that that this band part
excuse
when you had your media badge
and you walked in you did your thing you
set up you had your interview
and you talked to
your peers you talked to uh the
developers you talk to ceos you got the
time you got quality time right
it turned into what i can get out of you
when they started selling the ticket for
120 something dollars it it really
turned and this and this is their own
downfall and they brought this on their
self the pandemic just finished you off
you did this to yourself they didn't
value us
no they didn't and there was no actual
perks you know what was the last year of
the true e3 okay
it was the last true 2016 probably 2016
2017 was five
yeah it was the one where we was outside
when we when we stood outside with major
nelson in the fire pit
oh come on one of the last years they
gave you a bunch of nice stuff at game
yeah but you know what
listen
like
let me let me tell you break it down let
me let me tell you the difference
that's when the developer was getting
your attention going for your attention
true they were giving you as much stuff
as possible for you to spread the word
about their situation factual
this was when it turned
when they had the casual joe come in and
they said you know what i could sell
this cool stuff that i was giving away
why should i go out and invest remember
the year that we invested two thousand
five hundred dollars in t-shirts and i
handed them all out oh yeah
because again
you have to
give to get yes
they decided nah i'm not giving anything
you're gonna give me
and people brought and the more money
they made
the more the soul left
so how many times did you say to
yourself oh oh okay we can't go to e3
this year um because it doesn't feel the
same you wasn't looking forward to the
event itself you started looking forward
and you made things up to your
relationships tim dawg oh yes oh i'm i'm
gonna i'm gonna see colt out there but
we started okay brad you coming we
started forming our clicks megatron
everybody you know l boogie everybody
and we started making our own reasons to
be there other than the actual event
itself and then when we got there we
said it was more of a meeting
at that point yes there you go
yeah hey shout out to bone in the chat
the cat i'll jump in it's
it's bittersweet you know look i'm at
that point i mean we talked about it let
it go like i finally i i'm finally at
that accepted space yeah you know what
i'm saying and it's just like because it
it's a soul crusher for me you know as
an og like
it's one of those things it was magical
right you know what i'm saying
inspiration you could it was the
inspiration it was literally
gaming's mecca like you got to make a
picture to make if you're real if you're
real real about that life yeah i
remember how minuscule it was kind of
like we never saw nothing like that we
never had a network dedicated strictly
to gaming and you created this event
bridge yo this is for you being a
football guy you ain't a sports guy
guess what this is this is for you bro
tune in you see the developers you see
right behind the scenes you see what
goes into this fashion and then you get
the epic reveal and guess what
on top of that you get to see what's
coming out for the future for the future
live on stage big spectacle presentation
and then all of a sudden it just starts
going
okay you know yeah they
it was so magical
me and king used to have to go buy a
tape
yep
a e3 tape just it came out a month that
came out a month later 20 dollars yep
to find out what happened and it you
you'll have magical moments you'll have
the moments out of the sentencing stage
you know where they they call me like yo
you want to do uh halo 5 and they got
like a statue or lock and a statue of
chief and whatever whatever you know all
that's going on i ran's in like i don't
even know ran at that point he became
the man of the billion like yeah and you
didn't even come up and say hi i didn't
know you were too hollywood you were
with the elites
he was on a different place
he was on the stick
where they looked down at people and he
had his shirt on and his nipples and his
nipples was definitely coming
are you sure his nipples were covered
too but like i saw the video but we're
running like people don't realize like
fan fast
you know what i'm saying and this bro it
was different i remember a time they
rented out the whole club and it was
like
rod ferguson
ron ferguson let me play the new joint
nobody got 4k 60 gears ultimate i
remember the bethesda moment and no one
ran a show better than bethesda
obama
they made me
break my religion to eat meat yes and i
broke out and felt like he was dying 10
seconds later oh yeah right you remember
yo my whole body i look like a lizard
yeah yeah like
i was looking i i
i remember like leaving a conference
even it was when you're not happy like
2018 yeah or whatever that's what the at
i forgot which one it was addict me you
saw
and we just went live right after it was
18. i think they were like no 17.
because i didn't go to 18. yeah okay so
it was seven two um it was one of them
to 1916 and 17. yeah it was what maybe
it was 19 maybe it was 19 we was upset i
think that one of the ones we came up
with
i don't think solve went to 19. there
was one where it was me you would solve
yeah shout out to ubisoft for having a
whack
they had
like 20 boxes of pizzas stocked up there
right
all the boxes was empty
we got there at 305 and all they gave us
wait so you saying that that party was
sponsored by little seizures bro
a red bull they had a bunch of red bull
though and all the red bull you could
dead freezers
when we first got there it was papa
john's it wasn't little seizures it was
popular
like eight or nine refrigerators full of
red bull and when we got there we were
like okay let's get some papa john's
pizza opened it it was empty
then there was a table beside it that
had something else it was like bread
sticks or something all that stuff
let's just say let's just say the
ubisoft wasn't it
they did end up bringing out that uh
that fast food joint yeah but it was
like it was hours afterwards
also we got a shout out by yourself
because like what what i used to like
is you know you go there you get you get
the little roll up you know you kind of
had to probably bro we came we had to
kind of like stand out in a mall
overnight like like you you like you
know kids line up for jordans
like
like it was literally sleeping on the
floor sleeping was that was 2016. you
guys were
uh but like a like a mini mall yes and
they were like oh we need to have a
raffle because too many people showed up
right oh and then it was like you had to
wait overnight i was flying in because
that was saturday that was
was that that was friday
yeah i flew in on saturday
and i just got walked right into the
microphone
real quick
like
let me say something i would say
something
that was a fiasco like that they had
these raffling stuff it was literally
that's what the jig got out of tickets
yeah and he kept passing them out to
people that's never been to e3 and
what's funny is like even after they had
that so you know people pretty much like
they were like yo if you didn't get a
ticket you got to go home yeah so
everyone that went home we found out
later that microsoft worked with the usa
and still got them on got them yeah but
here's the thing this is what i knew
me and you
were gonna be friends
me and you because 20 let's say 2015 i
go by myself
king hits me says bro you are not i see
you on my xbox dashboard you are not
leaving me next year i'm near so 2016
can't come the whole crew then i forgot
what year you come right so then i think
it was no i went 16 16 right but the
first one was the same year right
now
which one was the
right but this is the year when it got
spooky and everybody started to catch on
to the fan fest and they started to come
and then they like
they were like guys
we don't have enough tickets for
everyone
yeah we're going to do a raffle guys
and i saw attic face like bro ida blew
so much money to fly out here
are you telling me i'm not guaranteed
and you just see a mall of people the
fear and destruction people are sitting
down sitting down and you got you got to
keep people by how many people people is
in this thing so people so many that you
couldn't walk through and we're not
talking like a small mall
so they on the megaphone and if they
give it out everybody raffle ticket
numbers red
so
trust me i know because i'm at home and
they're telling me about this on the
phone
like oh man it's a good thing that
you're like locked in can you do this
because they're wrapping so when i fly
in the next day
i you know i get picked up and i go
there with like south megatron and those
guys
and we could see everybody lined up who
slept overnight in the in the in the box
those are the ones that made it that
made the cut right and here and here i
get i could just like come right in the
microwave you're really gonna say this
going to say it again i'll say it again
because the thing was it was like this
is what i knew we was friends because
it literally came down to we looking at
our tickets there was probably 40 people
left 40 people like we got like the
littlest details matter yeah like 40
people left
our numbers ain't getting called
and i'm like damn
addict's not and carl gets the first
number so i get the first number now
mind you my
e3 is on the line
this ticket i'm in i'm good if i
and i'm like nah that's my man
he flew out here
he looked at me he's like cog really i'm
like nah brother i can't have you fly
out here i literally i didn't even catch
it i sat down for a minute because i
fell away i was like i don't want to
turn this and i said nah that's you the
bro this is for you
and he left so i at this point now i'm
out right and then he wins again he wins
again and this is where i gave you my
ticket yeah and then and then you went
off my team it didn't get in regards so
that it happened so i'm staying now it's
like down to the last 15.
and then i gave behind the kick again so
i'm like that kid got to get in
three times baby so i said all right boo
can't get him wow and i'll just like
this is where it pay off to be and
what's funny is this is where it pays
off
he messes his joint up though
no he was gonna go he would like he was
about to go kog was going to give him
the last ticket because he got it again
and black was like man i don't i came
here to drink well i don't care
i remember that that one got emotional
because it was like that's what you know
if your friends were cause i'm like i
don't really want to go
i was like i want to see phil i want to
microsoft that's the first time i saw i
was thinking about the big lights big
house steal a ticket from somebody
remember when when cory was called
little aunt jackie yes
she got bad corey was black was drunk
she they they did everything in the
world to keep him out yes
and she looked at him when he got in
with the ticket
what
what what was it
some some dude and his girlfriend won no
he wanted his girlfriend didn't win
right
and she wouldn't let him go unless they
both won
so she had she handed uh black his and
black went up to this chick was like i
got it the look of despair
how the hell did you get
everything for you
it's like she found the numbers on his
thing and went and told him don't call
this stuff
you're black lucky you got it but look
it was it was it was dope we ended up i
think that was the equipment from wrong
i'm gonna say that's the forza museum
year yes where they had the forza
rooftop party was in the vintage cars
with the ashton's with the with the with
the bougie food
you know what i'm saying 2017 they did a
raffle but it was online yes shout out
to you i don't know
yeah you fell asleep in the museum cory
chapel um i remember that you was drunk
you fell asleep
but um and then
shout out to aaron greenberg shout out
to greeny and then the parties and then
everything else but look it was such a
good thing it was such a good time and
it it just you know what you get
that's the memory though
that's why i can't 100 like look is e3
needed no it's not uh you know we have
way more outlets i would say on the
social aspect it's not needed right but
as far as like industry media
influencers i do think something is
needed
it's just not e3 now like keep in mind
like
i feel like the issue was
the esa felt like they were bigger than
the gaming industry like they could come
make shots that everyone would have to
listen to and when they started having
that energy i don't know exactly what
they did because i know there was a
little bit of friction between them and
sony before they actually pulled out
inevitably but
it's like
you're making people upset they what
they lost the reason they lost e3 and
they had to shut that down eventually is
because they lost the ability to to
combine the entire industry into one
event yeah yeah once you lost that
you've lost e3 eventually they lost sony
the ea that's why i feel like
as long as jeff does it in a similar way
it doesn't have to be identical he has a
better chance to do it because he's got
sony on his side microsoft messes with
him he can do that what they originally
did and then
like the avengers for one event that's
what my last point was before you get
out of here which was i'm hoping
jeff seizes the moment and do does what
you say
too much for him and everything turns
into an ad fight
we hope not
on the side of his pants on his belt i
do think if he drops the ball e3 might
try to come back i will say like i said
all i want if it's possible that's uh
that's a market you're going to
regret
even if the city is different or like if
you could pick a centralized location
that's what made it special it was a
centralized location where all the
luminaries all the who's who and all the
information was in the world bro we'd
walk down the street regular people out
i don't want them back
you don't want that comment
that would on that
this elitist
let me call it all i can't have that
it's not a leader i just don't want no
no it is like
you have every right to feel that way i
don't think that i'm trying to conduct
interviews i don't think that's true
yeah yeah i see you you have for
yeah that's true i don't think the issue
was bringing in you know the common funk
i think the issue was not trying to find
a middle ground between consumers
that was the only possible way of making
everything work
yeah i think that makes sense though
because especially with the special
badges that we would get the media
versus the normal public uh one because
the ones i opened would get those or
maybe let's say we get it early and we
get to talk to everybody before and then
you open it up terribly with the others
looking like they're trying to act like
they you yeah get out of here
like directly behind the curtain and
that would have been a different story
right i personally i i feel about that
no you saw listen shout out to kratos
for because me and him talking he's like
yo i'm gonna pay the thousand dollars
i said don't you do that i said i
already know what the badge bring you
they said that you're going to eat with
these guys and all you do is go in the
lunch room where they at and you can't
interact with them
i just feel like the only reason that i
can't say about not inviting consumers
and stuff the people of hobby it's like
do i remember back then when you know
you don't have media access
it's like small outlet
that is something
that i personally feel like every gamer
should be able to do one time one time
no no you know what
i can't put myself in a situation where
i'm putting down like i'm being the
gandalf for the tunnel and say you shout
out
that's right you shall not pass you know
why i don't care and that's you shall
not pass because i didn't have media
access right cod that is correct but we
haven't [ __ ] let us into there
[ __ ] where did you find me at when you
saw me
you was in the vip section media room
yeah but you had friends well we can't
put your circumstance in every
you had the way that led to your outcome
now everyone has that no that was
because of you
it was because of you because somebody
said something about you and i had
confronted that individual so that
individual said you know what i was
wrong and i apologize
how can i make it better real man
he said something on me and somehow you
get benefited
he says okay you know why because i
stepped to him because you're my guy
right
so you're not going to do that you mess
with one you mess with all right you
guys got cigars off of that he got to go
to a media room
[Laughter]
i like that look we got a rebel i want
um i know you went to one but what
if e3 is dead
based on this
what's your favorite e3 moment
the moment when i was able to hit a
million game store with ori with uh phil
spencer mikey barra and jessica chobot
that's probably the best
fire fire honey what else could i say
like
unless you mean not personal just like
watch so that was the personal and then
what was your favorite watching
moment
um
there's been a lot of cool ones i i do
remember
just because this prompted a lot of salt
and one of the greatest memes to come
out of neo neogas
when um
the dude walked up behind don matrick
tapped him on the shoulder
and final fantasy 13 trailer started
playing
and it was coming to xboxes at the time
it wasn't
and oh boy were people upset
remember
remember when uh remember when ted dog
slipped uh fell asleep for a couple of
yeah
favorite personal and at the moment so
basically two i think my my favorite
personal
is the very first time you walk into
that conference
when you see the
light in the background you see the
lights going back and forth like
like
you made a big sound baby when you're in
that room
the most satisfying feeling because keep
in mind this is after i went through the
uh the the the ruffle tickets
it's after i went through that after i
slept
it's after i slept through the entire
night on the ground
like like we earned those we wasn't like
randy got escorted in the back he wasn't
random thor bougie
he had the ground we had the work
and i would have to say i'm messing with
red the best experience like besides the
personal one like
i i remember the year i left
uh there was
the uh the year i didn't go with you
guys 2018 is when he announced all those
studios being bought oh yeah and i
remember i at the time i was a panelist
on planet xbox and we were live
streaming it and i will never forget
kidsmove was a little bit ahead of us
just a little bit like two or three
seconds he started freaking out right it
was enough to see the most crazy
reaction i've ever seen in my life for
this and i don't know just that joy to
this day i remember yeah
that's real that's real because it was
like just keep in mind it was like every
five seconds like because it was five
studios there's a lot like you're oh my
god
that's what it was like
no no that was big but i'll never forget
what he says and we have a fifth studio
and smooth's like oh my god
i do remember that kid went crazy
absolutely king tubal was personal for
e3
and what
moment
was the best e3 moment um
best e3 moment i ain't gonna lie
when i uh first talk to phil dominus max
you know he could he gave me the
political answer but he did
because he asked me you know how was the
show i said it was good
and you know shaking somebody's hand
when they firmly shake your hand and
bring you in close and said no
what's the real
how was the show how did you like to
show what's up i said you want the truth
he's like yeah
i said why the hell did you end on
somebody else's ip and not hours
and he said business
respect respect
respect because he had a foresight on
something else that i didn't he had
information that i wasn't privy to
it was a need-to-know situation
coming on game pass
that information that situation there
so
but okay my personal is too personal
let's go
because they they weren't for me
over them
it's for two individuals that i loved
daily
one was monkey oh hot monkey lover went
viral
no yeah
not that
it was the fact that he didn't have a
media pass
and you know me and him driving around
the city and corvettes doing everything
together he came out there to hang out
with me
factual and um
i said um
let's go i got my media pass
i said let's go he had this camera so
you got your camera on you he said yeah
i said let's go
i said don't say nothing just follow me
walked in the door
showed him my immediate passing he was
like who's that someone get my camera
man dang gonna argue with a six foot
white no me and him
like they're not gigantic i'm not
messing with y'all y'all look like y'all
was running the whole situation what's
funny is we do that a few times not just
once like a few times
but the next one
was destiny
two okay okay
and um
i had uh the pc
oh yes backstage with bungie
uh to play the demo
right the the nobody got a chance to do
that and you got to record it on your
own we had to wait online like a very
ridiculous i was able to cut i didn't
have no line there was no line i had a
scheduled meeting that i went in
everybody scheduled it for me
i walked in the door
but aunt was standing there i said aunt
you got your camera
you said yeah
i said let's go
conference on the spot
and we went in there
he recorded he took pictures he did
everything and he got a chance to play
but those are two people that i love
daily and the fact that i was able to
facilitate certain things with them
mm-hmm
made it way better oh yeah i would jump
in
personal level
first one because there's a nervousness
like what the hell are you doing
you are jumping into a plane in
california
you don't know anybody by yourself
yeah and it's like i get off the plane
shout out to wagga man he's one of the
first people i see
and he's like hey man i was like yo is
this the he's like xbox fanfest yeah
yeah so i get this that was the only way
about my dream
i just wanted to be in a press
conference
i just wanted to know how it feels like
live reaction phil spencer all these
guys
saying the stuff live that's all i care
i really didn't care about e3 the show
after
i'm more cared about that's it and that
was fan fest provided the direct ticket
to that
so i get there i've seen megatron
l bugs you know all these people i don't
know who they are
and the ruler comes up hey right hey you
know callie holmes in the building
holding me down you know what i'm saying
oh we're gonna go over the fat burger
cuz you never had fat burger cups all
right
you know what i'm saying this i'm a new
york yo you do y'all bone in everybody
you know what
so we go and i just meet these people
and it just grows and we sitting there
we in a mall
i don't know anyone but all i know is we
all love games we all love gays and we
say we about whatever's about to happen
the night ends
they lock us in the mall
we on the floor sleeping on concrete and
this is an outside mole this is not an
inside comfy no we're in
outside
so
morning happen you know you're
developing these friendships whatever
whatever
i never forget like
you just start to see a caravan of
people
they go aaron greenberg
there goes kudo who i believe was
hololens
they'd go
wait a minute is that fergus okay oh is
that the turn 10
okay
oh you something like a like a wwe thing
with the limo yeah it's like they just
coming into the mall one by one and they
shaken
everybody hand on this line
hey man we're gonna reward you you guys
thank you for you like they didn't then
they giving us a little care package
that little state of decay a little
little food in it you know what i'm
saying so we like all right you know
what i'm saying
that cake man come dope he's fairly new
at the time
phil dominance maximus really expensive
so hey like yo talk to phil you could
talk to a bird all right let me go so i
probably would fail for a minute i'm
like phil
why i don't got no baseball game though
i said that he looks at aaron
he's like yeah why don't we get that
face
like mary had that look like marketing
i'm ob
we kind of talked about this at the time
i was like it's unacceptable yeah i
don't have because at the time you know
you could develop your own so anyway
that goes on there's this other little
guy in the corner don't know who he is
not very non-descript he's with greeny
beardy god i'm like who is this guy
nobody knows who he is bill stillwell
and i'm like he comes up hey what's up
man what's going on i was like i hope
you like the show tomorrow
i'm all right
no no no
at the time it was built i had no idea
oh bill so then the show go and no and
then i shot and said you're just aging
them they're like cog you're gonna get
to go to e3 i'm like don't guess me i'm
i'm good with just this the next day
they take us to the usc um center usc
campus breakfast come through with the
big gourmet breakfast fee
they give us the shirts the little xbox
you got to wear the shirts
today
okay cool
phil comes back out just want to thank
everybody for coming
up and just to let you know
every single person is going to e3
[Applause]
oh my god phil said we're going
then they put us in a little exact
executive live on the buses was out we
go to the conference and like addict
says when it hits you and them dark
lights of strobe lights and that stage
and you like
welcome to the e
you made it nobody can't tell you
nothing at that point they come out on
stage
i see mikey borrow i see them and they
like look guys you know we got an
announcement
what are they talking about you know
never before done
xbox back compact to this day
the loudest pop i have ever heard at a
conference yeah and you could do this
right now
it's free
and then i look over and i see that
guy that i saw before that i who he was
i was like bill's that he got the smile
like ah i'm like you was holding so we
just vomit like yo how did y'all do this
this is crazy it was it was a thing so
that 2015 is always going to be special
because at the end of the day look iop
wouldn't exist and i told er at the time
i want to start a podcast you know what
i'm saying and we're going to bring you
guys through you know stuff like that
and it was just it was magical as far as
other moment
for me that was the person but as far as
like another e3 i would say 2018 like
hockey because
it showed let's be real ran
xbox we weren't sure during the xbox one
era how committed they were
let's be real you know i was thinking
back to when the attic was talking about
the studios and he was like you got 30
now or whatever and he's like coupler or
whatever whatever it's like hey remember
when xbox only had five studios yeah
yeah bro i remember the only five i
remember it was fresh off of the this is
how you trade like they were getting
pummeled yeah somebody was coming it was
it was bad like to even say you even
liked xbox was it was kind of like like
wow
you're getting the stink guys
that had uh halo wars 2 super lucky's
tale bro
you'll appreciate this blaze used to ask
me like why do you even like that system
i like the community and the
infrastructure and i like multiplayer
co-op games
go to the crib after the sony show and
we see the god of water so the e3 one of
dreams yeah and we like afterwards i
never forget what we saw that was like
oh
[Laughter]
mom well i don't know how they go over
spotted that
so 2018 was supposed to be literally
yeah if i remember correctly the first
thing we really said is like well it's
over this is
it was over right so 2018 was the hope
because
you come out phil comes out and you just
see what is it minecraft whatever it was
like one or two you're like okay
and then that graphic keeps getting
bigger and bigger and studio and then
you're like wait they got ninja theory
what they owned playground games
compulsion like what is going on like
they own them what is happening and
shout out to king one of the most gays
fans of g-max i don't know how he did
this this man gets backstage better than
anybody i know
he got exclusive interviews with the
heads of ninja theory he got exclusively
remember when we interviewed the
president of bleeding guys right there
yeah
bro it's listen for those who haven't
experienced you remember that time she
said um because she saw me again the
following year
and she's like oh come on come on come
here i'm like what's up she was like yo
i got a whole bunch of merch
your friends need anything i was like
yeah cool monkey was like i need a
skateboard
look yo it was it was a special time
it's a shame for those who didn't
experience it and what we just hope is
that you know jeff and keegley could try
to if they're gonna bring it back to a
physical event try to get the spirit
back and try to get everything i just
want microsoft to do fans huh yeah
even though i didn't get a chance to go
and that still bums me that i might not
ever get that opportunity that's what
that's right
yeah i know true that's true no that is
you're being at pax this year
nah not not this year i i got approved
for it but foreign
that's that's the cool thing about it
you can always it's always next year no
doubt
rest of peace was good for me yeah
what's up for you
for me on that one man uh and it sucks i
wasn't there to have like the actual
that's the thing you know obviously
nothing will compare to actually being
there and meeting everybody and
everything but
uh the one
obviously the one that started all i
guess you can say and this is back where
i was watching g4 like religiously you
know and and i was watching the x-plays
and the attack of the shows and going
man this is really good man it's
something for gaming and then they keep
talking about e3 i'm like one guy's name
is e3 and he was like oh yeah this is
gonna be a big
big show this is the showcase a game or
something going on so it's a special
okay i'm tuning it
i watch this i see
everybody i see all these games they got
the passes on everybody's talking about
the games we're seeing the gameplay
demos we're seeing the presentations
and then we get into the epic reveal and
ken kudoragi shows off the ps3 and then
he says the infamous price tag
aside from that price tag which didn't
didn't even bother me because you know
it wasn't my money i was laughing i was
on my parents budget
i was like
this is
lit you know you got the games you got
everything all these cool reveals and
the funny thing about it is i was like
one of only a handful of people i felt
like in my class when i went to school
and i was like oh yo did you guys see
the ps3 days like there ain't no psja
i'm like you guys just see ether
yep
the e3 though that stood out for me
personally
and will always be like that just that
badass epic moment like you will always
remember when this was synonymous with
playstation this is the one where i just
thought sony
really just what he was doing he had
everybody he was dancing i know which
ones
you know i'm talking let's go i'm about
to go ahead and do it
e3
2016. oh lord orchestra oh lord
everything when you hear this little boy
playing with these toys and goes and
you're a boy and you guys
cradles coming to the out of the shadows
and then it cuts to corey barlog playing
in this game you got monitors around
this man laughing at the crowd go crazy
i'm throwing actions doing everything
that's still so one of the epic most
happy things ever and on top of that we
even won't talk about the intro of that
oh god about the orchestra everybody was
sitting what kind of song is this that's
from vikings
dance oh my god and then you like it and
then they they give you the confirmation
for the first time ever a live orchestra
is going to play
for every single game reveal at this
show days gone the most crazy moments
where he's like getting about damn like
all these zombies coming at him he's
shooting and you got the the the
orchestra going with the beat
and to the tension you got the
spider-man king you're always
and this is from insomniac what what
let's go that's what i'm talking about
it's like dog they had everything and
then they pulled at my heart yeah i told
you
when i first came on here
what was the game that got me in the
platformers king
crash bandicoot
that sold me on the playstation it was
the game that that inspired me to get a
playstation one it was crash bandicoot
we got the epic reveal of crash
bandicoot after years of speculation
yeah
silly uh
silly pr oh yeah like charlene like he
knew everybody was waiting for crash but
he comes out with a crash medical shirt
he said sorry no t-shirt today but we're
bringing back the original crash yes
i was like you know what
i'll take it in the show take it bro
insane
wasn't that the same year of was final
fantasy
7 remake that year too or next year no
it was
next year okay and then when was so when
was the shenmue in one
moon was before that i think right
wasn't there because that one was
all that same year i thought that was
like one of them was it was so fantastic
i think all that happened in the same
world bro they was calling it the e3 of
dreams
that was 2016. wasn't it all i know
i've seen someone in there
tell me i'm right that's how real it was
it was just like
if there was a moment i was jealous of
because you know again i'm wearing mind
you just before i even really was
pushing the youtube thing i had my
laptop i was in
my room with the last time i'm watching
this going crazy mm-hmm
i'm seeing it going there was a there
was a damn show that i would want to be
part of just to be there to get
everybody's reaction it's that looks
like it was 2015. okay and if it wasn't
that one it would be the ps4 reveal
where it where for the first time ever
gamers legit felt like they made a
difference last thing it ain't about the
price review
it's the simple fact that everybody
voiced their opinion and that we were
heard and we made change and it was that
big for everybody so i'm saying
everybody walked away happy
and
2016 is one of those things where it's
like bro
how can you not just be a fan of gaming
when you see this you know what i mean
we got gaming doing stuff like this and
getting people this height people
screaming getting emotional they see
kratos and and all this like this is
what i wanted absolutely that sucks i i
probably would never see that again on
an e3 stage and i'll probably be
relegated to watching that at a game
awards show or a pat you know what i
mean that's the thing
the way you're going you're going to be
at a game award show yes you'll be there
bro that's your video i appreciate that
yeah facts look we got to wrap up we
could blow v8 for hours randy's like
randy's like you told me this is gonna
be short
like we had so many good memories of e3
i knew that tom
no dj no more four more hours stop
anyway
what's up what's up
wrestlemania this is wrestlemania this
past week was uh
8th 8th anniversary of uh
philip uh spencer aurelius whatever
however king says it
film dominus maximus really yeah
the eight years
uh wow as head of xbox wow beautiful i
can't believe it's been that long
he wasn't the one hey grind my gears
where you at i'd leave them alone
there's still people to this day that
want john matrix
i don't know what's funny
we've been covering
like the majority of last generation
like we've been doing this for a minute
we're doing it for a minute but like i
said we ilp we owe a lot to e3 there's
no doubt look we gotta get get this
super chats riled up i'll do the poll
all right with the latest revamp of
playstation plus as it currently stands
do you view this as a viable competitor
to xbox game pass the choices are a yes
multiple generation of playstation game
libraries blockbuster catalog that will
evolve and sheer volume of titles b
no without first par party playstation
studios
launching day and date oh you're funny
i'm making or not streaming options for
legacy titles it is a lesser service or
sea i don't care we revolt if veda is
not added to the damn service
proctor vote when it goes up salute to
the legendary man with the million rand
outdoor 19 big cloud gaming hog
lore hustle and motivate all pulling up
to help us out for solve during his not
so tough he's at work time that i can't
talk about but uh first let's start with
true
i was randolph say [ __ ] where's the like
option in that poll for like d where
it's like basically says
i talk crap all the time about
subscription services on twitter but now
i love it because sony has
where's that option i was thinking about
it but i was like it would be too
personal
i don't care i only like subscription
services but it's for my favorite
platform
i was going to do it i was going to do
it
yeah yeah
but look bro yo first of all salute to
you for pulling up man at last minute
and always been love from you and always
enjoy having your perspective if it
takes where can you find people find you
what you got going on listen to me i got
nothing going on cog you know
nothing going on i got my nipples out
right now
the mystery is revealed
yes baby hit the switch baby let's get
this only fans going yeah
well yeah so you know no i um
show them your bill
tell me your bill
looking like thor from damn
i love it
well uh i'll be i i should be coming out
of my uh sabbatical this this month so
miss you we got we got the podcast with
uh the one and only jess corden
possibly possibly
might be some info on the next podcast
about something we'll be going
you never know because you know jess is
out here like dropping stuff with miles
down pa and checkpoints oh i know what
i'm saying
i'm about to put your money on timeout
somebody said let me get them nipples yo
yo
time out show us the build ran only
build they wanted you to have a only
builds page
they want the nipples they want them to
continue that needs to be a show that
needs to be a show that's what a
favorite best boss ever continue
yeah so i mean uh you know youtube
channel youtube.com slash round of thorn
19
where you can find all my
social media stuff and uh
it's been a pleasure gentlemen as always
you guys are amazing
brother thank you brother
love rock and of course the man i am so
proud of right now
killing it with the playstation
dev studio interviews killing it with
the channel killing up the problem had
some wwe legends on the show
killing it ign free you'd run it out of
titles man your intro is going to be
like it's going to be so crazy when you
come back it's like you keep adding a
new title and there's more i heard
coming it's more cool
[Music]
shout out the big cloud gaming the hobie
love what you are doing you know you're
killing it brother and i just love to
see the professional growth on so many
levels
i saw you in there
ah you like that
love to see the professional girl you
know what i'm saying but bro we proud of
you where can the five people find you
that don't know who you are what you got
going on
yeah man um
first of all i want to
give you your flowers real quick uh kya
i really appreciate
you know the conversation we had back in
2014
or 2015 i think yeah we had a real one
it was a real conversation you talked
about potential you talked about where i
could go and i didn't want to listen i
really i didn't want to listen then
things started to happen you know within
a year and i was like
damn it really did just it really didn't
click and i really appreciate you i'm
very proud and happy for you over there
with oculus and everything finding duke
i'm glad to see this podcast get to
where it was go from 50 viewers to
podcast guys to where we are now
appreciate you doing great things
industry got everybody knowing you're
getting flown out that's awesome
king you already know i talk to you on
boom show when i can't we we laugh at a
lot
of good play
when i say i love you like a brother i
really don't
appreciate everything you do for me i
appreciate you always having my back you
know for guidance
i appreciate that attic again another
one always in the chat always there with
the words when i need it
you emblaze when i you know when i do
something wrong i can count attic
[Laughter]
say
[Laughter]
me and blaze compete to see who he
listens to all the time
he raps
everybody read you a special i
appreciate you too but everybody here
these these four brothers of course
sovereign the rest of the team when i
say i appreciate y'all i support y'all
everything you do i'm here every week i
try my best even though i miss the show
i feel bad i feel like i did my selfish
service i always been selling stuff not
learning something i or i miss out on
some fun laughs i love it um and you
know this is before we even got to where
we are now for those you're wondering
where what i do
i work with ign as a freelancer video
game guides for them i met a lot of
awesome people i signed a deal with wwe
as media to
interview
wrestlers
as well that's right that's exclusive
right there iop i also have a big
interview next month with the creator of
the game awards and the creator of
summer games fest the one and only jeff
kelly that will be happening next month
we're gonna put each other down
put the damn channel in the description
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
more than you see sony
listen man you know on twitter all day
actually making moves happen and that's
the funny thing when i'm on twitter it's
always to announce something good like
for example i was interviewed twice
actually uh by vidiq i actually dropped
iop in the in the other one which
they're writing away from the right this
one was tube talk where it was viper but
they interviewed small content creators
making a big impact within the community
and that's where i was highlighted so
that was actually on twitter if you guys
want to see that uh it's on my twitter
handle big cloud gaming um i have a link
in my video if you want to show my video
my recent video it's in the description
there right there bringing the channel
in there
i i appreciate y'all and that's where
you can find me big cloud gaming youtube
twitch twitter and um every friday rgt
podcast what i host that's usually where
these interviews are that's usually what
we talk about gaming news everything the
whole nine yards and again it's our raw
opinions and um i've had the privilege
of having king going and a 101 i've had
kai going um you know i got a got a head
um attic as well you gotta get the crew
one one d show and so that's what we got
to do we gotta get the whole crew one
these days please no doubt i appreciate
y'all thank you very very much keep
doing the damn thing i'm gonna be tuned
in like oh man i can't wait when you do
that one that's that's buttonless right
there bro that was once a while i'm like
yo i'm tooting i'm taking no hey let me
let me tell you about you were killing
this so much that like when i do catch
your joints it's hard to follow you
because it's like i gotta try to ask
questions that they asked cause this ads
look amazing
i have so many things covered i i love
but you know i always be fourth thing
because the thing about it too i see a
lot of people try to get info out of
them for upcoming releases and i think
that's not really the right way to go
about it you want to i think you lose
the the actual
human side of the interview and now
you're getting to know the person it's
better to do that's why like i love
interviewing the the actors who bring
these characters to life because you get
to see
how you get to learn more about them
like for example agent 47 we interviewed
david bateson and david bateson was uh
incredible because he opened up so much
about you know which one was his favor
and i even told him about that epic
moment where we first got hit man we got
legit big crowds yeah okay remember
absolution when he walks in trying to
figure out the rules characters are
walking through he's like dude
that's what i'm saying like you missed
that human aspect so that's where it's
just it's dope absolutely proud of you
man again great contact love what he's
doing play
send him some love and even if you're
not a playstation focused go check it
out man quality stuff a lot of stuff
going on over there lord addict where
can the five people find you what you
got going on sir
follow me on twitter at lord addict iop
uh you can find me this wednesday at
5 00 p.m on the attic show with uh my
co-host hustle motivate
and uh this week we're uh we're going to
be having uh tiger travis
going to be interesting hopefully on
monday i'll have uh the new artwork for
the uh the podcast so hopefully i'll
debut it with that podcast want to uh
thank rand and uh you know big cloud for
coming on i want to thank uh big cloud
for letting for for having his camera
unless and letting us see his build
[Laughter]
the bill was lit
what are you saying sir we wait people
wait to see your bill
hit that like button we had a great show
yeah yeah like almost 900 at one point
nobody was hitting that like button why
don't you say nothing
better we got to do better we got to do
better
it's just like you know it's it's a
habit we got to improve what we need is
we need to we need like
you know how like we push a button for
like throwing one of the bushes we need
one for like like that
yeah something like that we'll work on
it
like and subscribe make sure you
subscribe to randolphdown19 if you ain't
already you know man he's on everybody's
channel yeah make sure i go to sleep he
pops up he talking in my head i'm like
lord kidding with his nipples
oh my god where can i find you what you
got going on sir
first and foremost i want to thank uh
our esteemed guests for showing up um
you know hoglaw oh lord what was it
yo
hogue is a gym he's he's he's he's a
special special special person
and and the way he breaks things down he
breaks it down for the lame and i and i
actually love that stuff
um what i like about hogue is he he
explains it in a way that my
ignorant ass can't understand yeah
i don't know nothing about law but he
explains it only that i can understand
that you can understand it um
ran
you okay rand had to let you know
exactly how elite he was
he said while y'all was laying on the
floor
because i remember i will never forget
seeing that and i was like wow somebody
got a million gamer score yeah
and the fact that i know him
and i talk to him fast it blows it blows
my mind
okay so and we were i couldn't even i
can't imagine
having a million game of school i can't
imagine it because i remember when me
and mr howe was going at it getting
games and he was trying to fit
this man is you you're savant sir and i
truly respect you and everything that
you're doing i love you to death i swear
you're the best king thanks brother you
you and your nipples i love you
the whole package is this really going
to be always all jazz about this yeah
we're telling jess
this will definitely get an extra
[Music]
[Laughter]
i told you in the beginning
when we started politicking
yeah to hell with everybody else keep on
moving do what you do
and what i said it and yo the fact that
you got
an interview with sean layton
where nobody could get but i wasn't on
no no no i was the homies that was all
the homies that was borrowed i was born
he got he got an interview with somebody
he got like four interviews with so many
of sony's first parties
the one where it was the potential we
had that conversation it was just
the fact that you that you're in this
space you're in this pocket
and you're multifaceted
like you're doing video games you're
doing wrestling and i and i talked to
cog about that space because we were
that's where we come from we come from
wrestling and you're doing interviews
with wrestlers mm-hmm
right now man
and the fact that you're a freelancer
vijay
brother
the sky's the limit and and and you will
be on that award show you will have your
e3 moment you will have that space and
that stuff is definitely going to happen
i do appreciate you and your time today
i swear god i know shout out to flames
yo um online pouch has asked rand if
manscape is good for shaving
bcx nipples at 9 00 pm where you can see
uh a bunch of um
rich thousanders
by statues
uh kos is coming back soon after pax act
actually you know that's set up shout
out to graphic card shout out to dallas
shout out to drum star uh for getting
stuff together um
and combat talk with the king is coming
back for aerospace versus you guys
it's magical
no doubt that's all i can say is magical
and the way we're going to change the
game we're going to change the game in
in a manner that people can't follow no
doubt all right so um you got the um
[Music]
our guests you can leave now if you want
because we are reading super chats but
um
so got a
let me find where we were yeah okay so
we got to find out two dollars from
ladies and gentle that builds like gt
seven
we got a ten dollar super chat from
donald talk nintendo already has the
perfect system february direct for the
first half of the year june for the big
reveals and holiday with a little for
next year september for early next year
reveals i mean i i'm not never to say
nintendo don't like you know have good
information
uh outlets we got to find out super chat
of don otaku then you have smaller oh my
he's continuing it then you have smaller
direct for specific games and franchises
or third-party partners in game pass
announcements xbox just needs to copy
that format
i agree to a point uh then we gotta
fight out the superchat from uh
from jd gamer he's asking the panel
what studio publisher is the first post
activision acquisition for microsoft
avalanche crystal dynamics 101 the
people who make hitman eldos the people
who make uh i'm not telling that
cryotech sago wb or someone else yeah
that's a lot
no random i mean
who knows
the thing about acquisitions they
take so long and there's so many things
to it it could be anybody
i'm gonna keep saying second to a second
but anyway
um
so then we got another five dollar super
chat from jd gamer
uh hold up king did you answer that real
quick what what studio after uh
activision microsoft going by ubisoft i
said it already give yourself okay final
super chat to the panel
what could save you three could becoming
part of pax help new management i accept
it may be gone but gone after i've been
uh i've been a few times i think maybe
he's heard that a few times to be honest
with you it'd be drastic stuff to uh
save e3 like and i don't know if the esa
themselves are willing to make those
kind of changes uh we gotta fight out
from dragon heart you be tv
hashtag
huh
dragon heart yob good dude
uh hashtag
peace love life keep up the great work
gents we gotta treat iron lords like a
like red sorry gold carpet premiere
let's go absolutely
then we got two dollars superchat from
chezz uh respect for you guys for always
showing love
uh has there been anything since i
started raising super chats oh i think
that was the last one so look we got it
appreciate y'all for coming out
everybody enjoy your sunday if that's
all
yes keep in mind uh we do apologize the
only things you could see in that screen
is super chats you don't see uh yeah if
you missed anybody we got y'all yeah we
it flames off
it's awesome
put your body here beef that's betty
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh